안녕하십니까, 시민턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 회장을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프. 7월 3일 금요일 아 주말을
앞둔 일부 순서 시작하겠습니다.
어저께 한국 시장 굉장히 안 좋았고
좀 있다 우리 유리프로도 얘기하겠지만
미국 시장도 썩 좋지 못했던 거
같은데요. 중국 시장은 어떻게 되는지
한번 알아보겠습니다. 왕부장님
부탁드립니다.네
>> 어제는
상 지수도 글로벌 동조화로 매너스
2% 좀 빠졌습니다. 흥승태그 지수는
매너스 0.4%을 4%을 빠주고
정시되면 3.5조 수준을 유지했어요.
업종별 좀 보시면 어제 소재 자유
소비제 업종이 강세웠고 반면 IT
커뮤니케이션 승업제 업정이 약세
배웠습니다.
저가 매수 자금 유입으로 거래배당주
어제는 좀 올라가고요. 배터 최원는
1% 올라고 충구 신화는 3% 정는
1% 올라왔습니다.
벌자 가격 요즘 또 반등 나오고
있고요. 그래서이 때문에 소재 권연주
어세는 올라왔습니다. 자금은
4.5%라고 5% 올라고 소부과는
3% 전동 관금은 7 5%
올라왔어요. 기계 수출 데이터 소조에
따라서 기계 관련주 어세도 반등
나왔습니다. 세밀 중고는 + 2%
서공 기계는 3.23% 올라왔습니다.
최근에 유럽조는 에어컨 수요 화대 등
얘기가 계속 나오고 있고요.이
기대감으로 가정 관영 주어세는
반단했습니다. 거래 가전은 1.4%
올라왔고요. 하열 가전는 0.5%
5% 세마지국는 1.6%
올라왔습니다. 어 태백 기업 실적
발표 후에는 주가는 계속 올라가고
있습니다. 어 순봉 홀딩스 염증 7%
완통 태배는 3.5% 신통 태배는
3.6% 나왔어요. 한편은 소비제
관련주 어제도 상대적인 강세를
보였습니다. 귀조마테는 0.8%
하디러는 4% 시트린는 2% 신
차이나는 0.5% 못퍼서 돌아왔어요.
이번에는 홍콩 태그 주 어제 좀 반등
나와 보습니다. 아리 빠바는 1.8%
올라왔고요. 비와디는 그 8%
리우토는 1.7% 쇼프는 2.3%
올라왔습니다. 다만 그 A의 권형주
어제는 다 빠졌어요. 기는 매너
7.5% 빠졌고요. 조이테크는 매너스
10% 공원는 매너스 8% 중제
5차는 매너스 6.5% % 허전
중신는 또 매너스 10% 하갖기로
했습니다. 신년물 교체 금리 여는
염증 8b 선상했습니다. 연물 구체
금리 염정 5bp 상승하고 외화
환율은 0.09% 영쿠퍼스
소포산되었습니다.
>> 음. 감사합니다. 네.
>> 어, 글로벌 증시 동조화라는 말을
가장 많이 반복해서 해 주시는
>> 말씀 중에 하나인 거 같아요. 너무
당연한 말이고 중국도 어저께 보니까
중국 지수는 상해 지수, 선전 지수,
CSI 300 전부 다 어 1% 이상
등락을 보이는 경우가 많지 않은데
어제는 전부 다 2%, 3% 뭐
이렇게 좀 크게 하락을 한 거
같습니다. 중국 본토 기준으로 부장님
그 상한가 하한가가 10%던가요? 어
뭐 기본 번도 시점 보면 상회 지수
그리고 신전 지수 이런 회사는
>> 어 플러스 마이너스 10% 중되고요.
>> 청후반 있잖아요. 샘포자 시작하는 거
플러스 마이너스 20%
>> 20%
>> 맞아요.
>> 홍콩은
>> 홍콩은 자게 없어요.
>> 없어. 네어 미국처럼 그냥
>> 미국처럼
>> 50% 오를 수도 있고
>> 뭐 70% 50% 오군요.
>> 그래서 어저께 한국도 메모리 주식들
중심으로 굉장히 안 좋았는데 중국도
우리 항상 뭐 CCL 동박 뭐 이런
등등 포함해서 전부 다 10%
줄한가를 맞지 않았을까라고 생각을
했는데
>> 어 여기 보니까 호전 주식 10%
조이테크 10%지만
>> 네
>> 한국보다는 얌전했다 그런 생각이
들어서 아닌가?
뭐음
왜면 충구 지금 한산종에 그 매블리
업체 아직도 없는 상황 있잖아요.
그래서 이거는 기존 다르니까 좀 잘
보고 있어야 되고
>> CCR PCB 업체들이 거의 10%
허준 수시는 대이잖아요. 어제는
10% 좀 빠졌잖아요.
>> 시전은 또 비슷해요. 느낌이 딱
비슷하고요.
>> 뭐 CCR 홀산는 매너스 8% 좀
빠지고 성공테크는 매너스 6%
빠졌어요. 네. 3 정작 그 삼성
전기 비슷한데요. 어제도 거의 13%
정도 빠졌어요. 음.
>> 음. 약간 그 트렌드가 좀
비슷합니다.
>> 음. 알겠습니다.
>> 그래서 그 반대편에 있는 그동안 쭉
어 수급의 쏠림에 피해를 받았던
업종이나 종목들은 한국도 그랬지만
>> 상대적으로 주가가 좀 좋았던 거
같습니다.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 이슈 종목 낙덕 주식.
>> 네. 낙주시는이 회사 몇 번 정도
리서치 좀 했습니다. 다만 주가가
많이 올라왔어요. 그 4월 달 하면은
리터치 자료준 분위가 그때는 3조
되고요. 지금 우증 8번조 되었어요.
그래서 지금이 뭐 뭐 거의 한 달 두
달 정도 따로 놨어요.
>> 나도 주시 충구 최대 그 배터리
이용바 제조 홀사였고요. 글로벌 시장
MS 30% 글로벌 1등이고요.
케판은 지금 15만 정도 되고
PCB용 그 비는 거의 3만 정도
됩니다. 1분기 실전은 전세
나왔습니다. 매출에는 동일대비 80%
증가하고요. 수익는 흑자했습니다.
어 1번기 GP 마진 11.7%
나오고요. 동기및 전분기 대비 다
확대하고 MP 마진을 1.58%로
동의 흑자 조항되었고 어 QQ는도
동의대 QQ는 플러스 0.8% 8%
올라왔습니다.이
실적 좋게 나오는 이유가 딱 두 가지
있습니다. 첫 번째는 자정후 마이클론
그 이하 돈박 있잖아요.이 부분 마주
10% 정도 돼요.이 부분은 비중
확대하고 있고 그리고 PCB 정자용
돈박 그쪽은 출화년도 증가하고
있습니다. 그래서이 [목을 가다듬음]
두분에 실전 좋게 나왔어요. 특히는
그 PCB 어용 그 동방 있잖아요.
지금 비발리율 30% 나오고
있습니다.
S 수증가 전기차 배터리 탁제 용량
화대 등에 따라서 돈바 수요는 원래는
동일대비 29% 증가 매년은 동의대비
20% 이상 증가할 것으로 예상하고
있고요. 반면은 충 몇 년간이
업그게는 케파 증선은 거의 안
왔어요. 축소되었어요. 아니면 계속
적자 나오고 있으니까. 그래서 원래는
공급제도 제한될 수 있고 내년은 또
거의 13%만 정가할 수 있어요.
그래서 원래 업계 가동률은 이미
93% 수준까지 올라하고 내년
추가적으로 선승 가능성이 있습니다.이
리퍼저 니가이 가동률 내년 아마
97%까지 올라갈 수 있어요.
[콧방귀] 어 동산 현재는 약
15만든 돈밖에 파유하고 있고 거프가
같이 동매 비조는 작년 25%에서
올해 50%까지 화대 예상이고요.
바지는 작년은 매너스 염증일만 외
정도에서 염증 자만 외지로 확필
가능성이 있습니다. 동우 청구한
리포트 보면은 배터리용 돈바 정자용
동반 수요 동반 화다에 따라서 매수
의견을 유지해보 제시했습니다. 원래
내년 내 혼년 순위는 각하 12.2억
위한 21.2억 여향으로 추정되었고
동의 대비는 3배 20% 145%
30% 증가 추정되었습니다. 역산화
하면은 원래 예산피는 약 38배 정도
되고요. 내년은 16배, 내고년
12배밖에 없어요.음이
홀사는 잘 나갔을 때는 뭐 PR는
대충 20회 정도 받을 수 있어요.
그래서 저도 그 내년 20회를
PR해서 TP는 9한 정도가 좀 뭐
개 나왔어요. 어제 종가 대비는 제종
30% 나올 수 있습니다.
>> 다만이 회사 리포트는 그냥 뭐
보표주가 제시하지 않았어요.
>> 음. 어. 보통 이런 중국에서 성장주
그리고 가장 많이 최근에 언급됐던 또
용어 중에 하나인 뭐 CCL 이런데
관련주면네. 어 제 기억 속에
멀티플이 한 30배 [목을 가다듬음]
그 이상이 어 타겟 멀티플로 적용이
됐던 거 같은데 지금은
>> 우리 왕부장이 20배 정도로 적용해
주신 것은 전방 산업이 이게 어
차량용 배터리여서 그런 건가? 왜
그런 거예요?이 음.이
>> 호전는 전는 그 차량용 배터리
배터리용 그거 돈바 만들었어요.
>> 되게 그 견정을 치열하니까 마지는 안
나와요. 적당했어요.
>> 지금 이미 그 계속 업그레이드 되고
있으니까이
여서 보시면 자우 마이클론 있잖아요.
이거는 완전 거부가 같이 가지
돈바까지 올라왔습니다. 밑에 거는 안
나왔고요. 그래서이 부분은 마진은
계속 되고 있고 특히는 최근에 PCB
정자용 그거 뭐 돈을 계속 그 만들고
있잖아요. 이거 마진 높아요.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 단기적으로이 비중은 아직도
높지 않아요. 왜 통째로 하면은지
50% 정도 되고요. 그래서 나머지
50% 여전히 저가 제 제품입니다.
>> 여기 세게 주기 주면은 좀 애매하고
나가 여기서는 스몰배를 적용하면은
나쁘지 않다고 생각합니다.
알겠습니다. 네.
>> 어. 같은 동박 업체인데 전방 산업이
어디냐에 따라서 그리고
>> 제품의 어떤 부가 가치 영역에 따라서
영업 밑에 표익률이
있는 건가?
>> 아 영업률은 우리 이상한 거는 충국
그 에너지 3에 영어 인율 안 보고
순위율만 봐요.음
>> 혹시 왼쪽 아래 표를 보실 수도
있으니까 여섯 줄이 있는데 맨 위부터
뭔지 한번 간단히만 좀 말씀드네. 첫
그 매출액
>> 두 번째는 동기 대비
>> 분기 대비 동기 대비 외출액 성장률
>> 그다음은
>> 그다음에는 순위 순위익네
>> 동기 대비
>> 그다음이 동기 대비 성장률 그다음에
EPS 맞아요
>> 그다음이
>> 맞아요
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 네
>> 다음에 기억을 또 못 할 거예요. 또
물어볼게요. [웃음]
>> 네. 알겠습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 중국 시장 여기까지
보고요. 어제 미국 시장 좀 좋지
못했던 거 같은데 유리프로와 함께
보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 어 말씀 주셨듯이 어제이어서 좀
어 센티체는 좀 부정적인 흐름으로
이어졌었는데요. 이제 하반기 시작한지
정말 이틀밖에 안 됐는데 메타가
[목을 가다듬음] 촉발한 케펙스
논쟁이 다시 이제 불을 붙여 목요일
미국장이었습니다.
지수부터 보시면 [목을 가다듬음]
SB 거의 보합권으로 마감했습니다.
그리고 이제 바우지수 같은 경우에는
1.1% 1% 상승하면서 이제 이거래
연속 사상 최고치를 경신을 유일하게
했고요. 반면 나스닥 같은 경우에는
어 1.6% 하락했고 이제 필반
지수가 5% 가량 급락을 했습니다.
이제 5일 기준으로 보시면 9.4%
4% 가량 빠졌는데요. 이제 어제
장이 뭐 단순히 뭐 위험 해피였다라고
한다면은 이제 제가 알기로는
비트코인까지 같이 밀렸어야 하겠지만은
이제 자료 기준으로 봤을 때 비트코인
그리고 금은 이제 동반 상승을 좀
소폭이지만 했고 이제 다우도 신고가를
기록했다라는 점을 봤을 때 시장
전체가 무너졌다라기보다는이 메타발
AI 케펙스 회수율 논쟁이이 AI
인프라 공급망이 좀 집중적으로
디레이팅을 일으킨 장이었다라고 이제
느낌 잡을 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이제 하단에이어서 보 하단 텍스트
보시면은 어제 고용 지표 발표가
있었습니다. 제 우선 2월 비은 고용
한 57,000명 증가에 좀
그쳤는데요. 시장 예상치보다
약했습니다. 또 이전 두 달치도
보다도 또 하향 조정이 되면서 최근에
이제 고용 회복 모멘텀이 좀 다소
식었다라는 평가가 좀 반영이 된 거
같고 실험률 같은 경우에는 4.2%로
2%로 좀 하락을 하긴 했는데 이거는
좀 고용 시장이 뭔가 강해서라기보다는
노동 참여율이 좀 떨어진 영향도
있었기 때문에 좀 마냥 고용 지표
관련해서는 좋은 시자로 보기는
어려웠다라고 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 좀 왔다 갔다 하는데
우측에 어 상단 이동해서 보시면은
이제 금리 쪽 보시겠습니다.
이제 이런 고용 지표 때문에 먼저
시장이 반응했던 건 2년물
금리였습니다. 그래서 이연물 국채
이념물 보시면은 4.14%라서
3.7b 하락을 했고요. 이제 2년물
금리가 아무래도 연준 정책금이 가장
즉각적인 제 지표잖아요. 그래서
고용이 예상보다 좀 강하게 약하게
나오면서 연준이 이제 당장 추가
이상에 나설 필요는 줄었다라는 해석이
좀 붙은 모양세입니다. 여기서 좀
중요한 점은 국채 10년물은 이제
같이 크게 내려오지 않았다는 점일 것
같습니다. 어제이어서 신년물이
4.48% 부근에서 거의 변하지가
않았고 상단에 이미지약 흐름 보시면은
소폭이지만 지금 상승을 했습니다.
그래서 2년물이 하락했다는 거는 고용
둔화로 뭐 연준 추가 인상 부담
완화됐지만 10년물이 보 아니면 좀
속했습니다. 했 했다라는 흐름을 봤을
때 뭐 장기 인플레이션이라든지 재정
그리고 오늘의 주인공인 키워드인 AI
케펙스 자본 비용 부담은 좀
여전하다. 그래서 금리 전체가 이제
편하게 내려오지는 못한 이제
흐름세였습니다.
업종별로 이동해서 보시면은 이런
흐름이 좀 더 명확한데요. 이제
고용투나 이념을 금리 낮추면서 시장
하단을 좀 받쳐 주긴 했는데 10년물
이제 높은 수준 유지하면서이 AI
케펙스 회수 논쟁에 좀 부담이 남았던
남았습니다. 그래서 그 결과로
기술주에서 헬스케어 그리고 방어주로
좀 로테이션이 나왔습니다. IT 정보
기술 쪽에 한 1.5% 하락하면서
지수를 좀 내렸고요. 커뮤니케이션
그리고 자유소비제도 더 약했습니다.
반대로 건강 관리 헬스케어 쪽에서는
어 상승세가 보였는데 2.7%로
7%로 가장 크게 상승을 했고 필수
소비제는 2.4% 그리고 유틸리티가
2.3% 올랐습니다. 그래서 IT
쪽이 빠진 분량을 헬스케어, 필수
소비제 그리고 금융 쪽에 받아내면서
SP가 좀 보합권으로 유지될 수 있지
않았나로 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 52주 신고가 쪽에도 이동해서
보시면은 그동안 이제 많이 등장했던
반도체보다는 헬스케어 중심으로
나왔는데요. 이제 하당 이제 중간부에
보시면은 총 이제 49개의 신가
종목들이 있었는데 제가 이걸 좀 추일
때 어떤 섹터가 가장 많이 나오냐를
기준으로 보거든요. 그리고 상승세랑
그래서 보시면은 절반 이상이 금융
그리고 헬스케어 쪽에서 나왔습니다.
하단에도 제가 뭐 신고가 49 종목
중에서 뭐 금융 16개 헬스케어
13개가 나왔다라고 말씀드리면서
금융이랑 헬스케어 쪽이 확실히
신고가를 많이 찍은 하루였고요.
이제 중간부 쪽에 또 종목별로 보시면
모더나가 10% 가량 상승을 했고
버텍스가 6%가 4% 다비타가 3%
오르면서 좀 헬스케어에서 상승세가
있었습니다. 금융 같은 경우는 이제
비자 그리고 올스테이트가 신고가를
기록했고 그 유일하게 이제 정보 기술
쪽 IT 쪽에서 크라우드
스트라이크라는 보완주가 또 신고가를
기록을 했는데 자 아무래도이 LLM
모델에서도 보안이 계속 이슈가 되면서
크라우드스크라든지 아니면 어제 좀
팔로 네트워스 이런 종목들이 계속 어
주목을 받고 있는 것으로 보입니다.
헬스케어 내에서도 좀 바이오의
상승폭이 컸는데요. 이제 모더나 같은
경우에는 뭐 코로나 이후에 뭐 암
관련해서 그리고 백신 관련해서
포트폴리오 재평가가 좀 붙었고 버텍스
같은 경우에는 뭐 소화 적응증 관련
신약 확대 승인이 있었고 그리고 FB
같은 경우에 좀 더 정책적인 이제
수혜를 받았는데 이제 트럼프 행정부가
이제 340 340비 이제 병원 약과
맞은 규제안을 뭐 통과했 어 좀
언급을 했다라고 합니다. 이게
뭐냐라고 봤을 때 이제 뭐 메디케어
파트 B 환자가 연간 약 800달러를
절감할 수 있게끔 이제 뭐 정책을
이제 진행을 하겠다라고 이제 한
흐름이었는데 이게 그래서 병원이랑
제약사 기준으로 약간 둘을 경쟁구도
본다면 병원의 약과 마진을 줄이면서
직접적으로 제약사 쪽에는 좀 마진이
갈 수 있는 그런 이제 행정적인
흐름을 보이면서 좀 주가가 좀 제약사
쪽으로는 긍정적으로 그래서
애급이라든지 기재들이진 않았지만
존슨앤 존슨이라든지 머라든지라는 대형
대형 제약주가 좀 강했습니다. 그래서
이런 대형 제약주가 좀 강하면서
시총이 크다 보니까 헬스케어 섹터가
좀 정책적으로 수혜를 받았고요.
금융에서는 이제 비자랑 올스테이트가
신고가 냈다라고 말씀드렸는데 비자
같은 경우는 말씀해 주시겠지만 뒤에서
이제 결제 네트워크 좀 방어적 성장성
그리고 올스테이트는 좀 보험주 전막
강세가 좀 반영이 됐습니다. 어
이렇게 보시면은 뭐 그래서 반도체가
빠지고 반도체 IT가 빠지고 헬스케어
금융적으로 이제 또 섹터
브로드닝이다라고 어제이어서 보실 수
있겠는데 어 섹터 브로든이다이
브로드닝이다라고 픽스를 하기보다는 어
AI 케펙스 논쟁에서 좀 벗어난
그러면서도 개별 촉매가 있는 종목들
대상으로 좀 신고가 그리고 좀
긍정적인 흐름세가 나왔던
시장이었습니다.
빅테크 쪽 어 좌측으로 이동해서
보시면은 이제 주인공 어제이어서 좀
메타였는데요. 멘타 같은 경우에는 뭐
AI 컴퓨팅 파워 그리고 모델 접근권
어제이어서 뭐 외부에 판매하는
클라우드 인프라 사업을 검토하겠다라는
보도가 나왔었죠. 그래서 이게 이제
어제는 한 8% 가량 상승하면서
메타가 처음에는 이제 일차적으로요
뉴스가 메타에는 좀 긍정적으로 해석이
됐었습니다. 반면에 오늘은 이제
5%가량 하락을 했는데요. 왜 이런
흐름이 지속될까를 좀 생각을 좀 이슈
쪽에서 다뤄 보고자 합니다. 이제
이미 메타 같은 경우 그리고 빅테크
같은 경우에는 막대한 이제 AI
인프라를 투자해 놓은 상태잖아요.
이제 그런 상황에서 일부 컴퓨팅
용량을 외부에 팔 수 있다면은 투자한
돈 대비 회수율 이제 ROIC를 높일
수 있다라고 이제 보일 수 있기
때문에 뭐 이제 메타가 어제는 좀
상승을 했었고 근데 이제 하루 사이에
이제 시장이 좀 더 근본적인 질문을
던진게 아닌가라고 저는 생각을
했어요. 그 질문이 뭐냐 하면은 이걸
그럼 왜 팔아야 되는 거냐라는 걸
텐데 이제이 질문을 그럼 이해하려면은
메타의 기존 사업 구조를 좀 볼
필요가 있을 것 같은데 이제 메타
기존 사업은 이제 AI 관련해서는
AI 수익화를 뭐 AI 자체를
API처럼 판매하는게 아니라 본업은
이제 광고 효율화이거든요.
그래서 AI 추천 랭킹 통해서
페이스북이라든지 인스타그램 그리고
릴스 체류 시간이랑 광고 전환율
높이고 여기다가 이제 AI 비즈니스
AI 그리고 커머스를 통해서 워츠앱
그리고 인스타그램 안에서 기업 고객
상담 추천 판매 전환 이제 높이는
그런 추천 구조입니다. 그래서 이제
메타 기존 AI 수익화 같은 경우는
광고가 이제 본업이고 이제 비즈니스
AI 그리고 커머스가 좀 확장
옵션이었는데 반면에 이번에 좀 새롭게
업사이드로 보던요 AI 클라우드 수요
같은 경우 그 클라우드 외부에 판매를
하는 거잖아요. 그래서 기존에 이제
내부 효율성을 높이는
본업이라기보다는이 커진 AI 케펙스의
회수율을 높이기 위해서 추가 자본
회수를 해야 되는 좀 옵션에 가까운
지표가 아닌가라고 보여집니다. 그래서
이걸 위해서 필요한 차원이 이제
학습용 GPU 클러스터 그리고 출론용
컴퓨팅 용량에 확대일 텐데
이제 뭐 그게 필요하다. 추론 그리고
이제 학습에서 필요하다라는 건 이제
디폴트고 근데 이제 문제가 될 건
이제 투자 규모일 거 같은데 이제
일반적으로 이제 유효 연산 차원을
자원을 이제 판매한다라고 이제 봤을
때 유효 연산 자원을 판다라는 말은
이미 확보한 영향 중에 일부가 남아
있고 그 자산에 이제 가동률을
높이겠다라는 의미로 해석이 될 수
있잖아요. 그런데 어 근데 이게
남는다라는 건 어 그럼 이제 필요가
없어지는 거 아닌가라고 생각할 수
있는데 또 동시에 이제 메타가
코어위브하고 이제 232년까지
210억 달러 규모에 의한 인프라
계약을 맺었거든요. 그리고
크루소하고도 1.6GW 규모 계약을
체결할만큼 좀 공격적으로 계속 용량을
확보를 하고 있는 모양생입니다.
그러면은 이제 어 유유 자원이
남는다. 근데도 투자를 계속한다.이
두 개의 이제 팩트가 동시에 진행되고
있다라는 사항을 봤을 때 지금은
이렇게 던질 수 있을 것 같아요.
정말 남는 용량을 파는 거라면 추가
용량 확보는 왜 계속을 하고 있냐?
음.
>> 그리고 반대로 추가 용량 확보가 계속
필요하다면 외부 판매는 이제 기존
AI 수익 그니까 기존 그 비즈니스
모델만으로는 투자 회수율을 충분히
이제 빠르게 증명하기 어렵다는게
아닌가? 그니까 기존 비즈니스 모델이
훼손됐지 않았나라는 질문을 동시에
던질 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서
여기에 이제 이코어이브 210억
달러라는 이제 금액 기준으로 보면은
개인적으로 생각했을 때는이 210억
달러 계약을 커버할만큼 내부에 이제
기존적인 비즈니스 모델이 돈을 못
벌어들이고 있는게 아닌가? 그래서이
210억 달러가 좀 미니멈
기존이다라고 봤을 때 그럼 그 이상의
돈을 클라우드 매출로 이제 벌어들릴
수 있을 것인가 앞으로 이제 메타의
향방을 좀 평가하는 이제 좀 지표가
될 거 같습니다.
추가적으로는이 해석 자체가 좀 반도체
쪽도 짚어 보시면 메타 하나에서 좀
끝나지 않았다는 건데요. 이제 돈을
벌어들이는 쪽이 있고 돈을 쓰는 쪽이
있다라고 계속 말씀을 드렸었는데
메타가 이런 식으로 오늘 이제
빠졌다면 그럼 반대로 돈을 버는 쪽인
뭐 반도체적으로 올랐어야 되는 흐름이
동시에 일어났어야 될 거 같은데 그와
반대로 어제이어서 반도체 추 계속
하락을 했습니다. 그래서 시장이 이런
흐름을 봤을 때 그러니까 빅테크가
돈을 못 번다라는 해석을 뛰어 넘어서
AI 자체가 문제 AI 케펙스 자체가
문제가 있는게 아닌가라고 한 단계 더
해석을 한 흐름으로 보여요. 그래서
여기서 이제 중요했던게 이제 메모리
쇼티지 관련해서는 계속 언급이 되고
있는데요 메모리 공급 보족은 여전히
이제 AI 수요가 강하다라는 팩트이긴
하거든요. 그래서 메모리 쇼티지라는
현상 자체가 사라진 것은 아니지만은
현재 이제 메모리는 빠지고 비테크도
빠지고 이런 흐름세가이 시장 투자자
입장에서는 뭐 쇼티지라는 현상 자체가
사라졌다. AI라는 현상 자체가
사라졌다라기보다는 그다음 질문으로
넘어가서이 쇼티지가 빅테크 케펙스의
증가 속도를 계속 정당할 수 있느냐를
좀 검증했으면 좋겠다를 이제 시장
투자이 주가 향방에서 좀 확인을 해
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
네. 그래서 이제 또 레버를 한번
드리자면요.요 여러 가지의 동시
다발적인 현상들이 일어나고 있는 걸
어떻게 이제 해석을 할 수 있고
그래서 그다음 질문을 어떻게 봐야
되냐가 앞으로 이제 하반기에 질문이
될 것이다라고 저는 좀 보여지고
그래서이 투자한 캡텍스가 누구의
매출과 캐시플로우로 더 빨리 돌아올
것이고 그리고 누구의 부채와 비용
부담으로 남을 것이냐 이것도
아니라면은 혹은 다른 성장 섹터가
있느냐를 좀 더 찾아보는 것이 이제
오늘 시장의 핵심 어제 오늘의 핵심이
될 것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 우리 큰 아비들의 자료를
보면은 강세장 속에서 또한 15%
내외의 그 지수 하락이 어 기억이 잘
안 나는데요. 뭐 1년인가요?
2년마다 한 번씩은 있다. 이렇게 어
그래서 강세장에서도 늘 그런 큰 폭의
조정은 있기 때문에이 강세장의 흐름이
꺾이는 건지 아니면 그런 강세장 속에
잠시의 조정인지 구분하는 것이
필요하다는 얘기를 반복해서 해 주고
있는데 보통 그런 강세장에서의
하락률을 계산해서 어 몇 퍼센 하락은
뭐 몇 1년에 몇 번 렇게 말해 줄
때는 기준이 항상 SMP
500이거든요. 그런데 SMP 500
기준으로는 뭐 10% 이상 조정 뭐
이런 건 지금 전혀 없어요. 그죠?
그런데 이거를 우리가 항상 그 아
최근에는 이제 필라델피아 반도체 지수
AI 관련한 종목들만 보다 보니까
어이 심정적으로 지금 시장이 무너지는
건가 하는 생각이 드는데 요게 어
일반 지수에도 적용을 할 수 있는
거면 어 이제 다시 강세장으로 접어들
수 있겠다는 조금 더 믿음을 가져볼
수 있을 텐데 요게 이런 서브
인덱스에도 적용이 되는 건지는 저도
잘 모르겠습니다. 그래서 어 반도체
일변에 투자를 하고 계시기 때문에
지금 시장이 더욱더 심각게 느껴지실
텐데요. 어 요런 부분 다시 한번
회복을 우리가 기존 투자 포트폴리오가
회복을 할 수 있을지 변곡점이 온
거는 맞는 거 같습니다. 그 부분
계속해서 업데이트를 드리면서 미국
시장 보도록 하겠습니다. 이상 미국
시장 보고 한국 아니죠. 가상자산으로
넘어가 볼 텐데 가상자산은 나쁘지
않더라고요. 하루 흐름만 보면
저녁이면 어떻습니까?
>> 네. 가상 시장 솔직하게 말해서 어
나쁘지 않았습니다. 그리고 오히려
좋아 보일 정도였는데요. 사실 비트
가격 그기동안 많이 소해 받았고 많이
빠졌기 때문에 좋다라고 생각해야
되는지 잘 모르겠지만 어제
결정적이었던 거는 비농업 고용 지수가
나오고 나서였다라고 생각하고
있습니다. 민노 고용 지수가
예상치보다 크게 사회를 하게 되면서
그 고용이 적게 고용이 되면서 어
이제 금리 인상에 대한 압박이 좀
줄어든 거 아닌가 하는 사람들이
기대감이 좀 반영이 됐고 실제로
패드워치에서 동결 확률이 굉장히
급등한 걸로 제가 알고 있습니다.
그래서 그러면서 달로 인덱스도
내려오게 되고 밑에서 간단히
소개드리겠지만 어 단기물 단기물도 좀
내려오게 되면서 그런 부분들이
비트코인 가격에 좀 좋은 영향을
미치지 않았냐 어 생각이 들고 그럼에
그런과 동시에 어 금 금과은 같은 거
그 귀금속들도 같이 상승을 했기
때문에 어 조금 더 정당성을 부유할
수 있는 어 어제 이슈지 않았나
생각을 할 수 있을 것 같습니다. 어
그래서 기술적으로도 하나 설명을
드리면 될 거 같은데요. 오른쪽에
비트코인 장기 차트 보시면 어 그
선을 간단하게 터치를 그 가볍게
터치를 한번 하고 내려온 부분 보실
수 있을 것 같습니다. 자 이게
200일선이 항상 그 바닥의 지표로
쓰여 왔었다. 역사적으로 작용해
왔었다라고 말씀을 드린 적이
있었는데이 200일선을 어제 터치를
한번 하고 다시 조금 어 어 내려오는
모습을 보여줬었습니다. 한
62,000불 정도 구간이니까 그
구간을 참고하시면 될 거 같고
비트코인 아무래도 가치 평가라는게
실적이나 뭐 언니에 의해서 나오는
것이 아니다 보니까 기술적인
움직임이나 역사적인 고점 처점 그리고
역사적인 패턴에 의해서 결정되는
경우가 굉장히 많습니다. 그래서이
200일선도 비트코인 입장에서는
밸루에이션 되지 않는 상황에서 굉장히
상징적인 의미로 작용할 수 있다라고
어인지를 하시고 조금 어 투자에
참고를 하시면 좋을 것 같다라는
생각이 들고요. 비트코인 휴인 그레드
인덱스 보시면 극단적 공포 구간이
11 아직도 기록을 하고 있고
비트코인 현물 ETF 순유출 순유출에
보시면 어 아직도 유출세를 계속
기록하고 있습니다. 어 한 10거일
이상 유출이 되고 기속되고 있다라고
어 제가 봤는데 한 300밀 정도
어제도 유출이 7월 1일 날도 유출이
되면서 안 좋은 흐름을 지속하고
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
제가 위에서 간단하게 소개시켜 드린
내용이지만 비노 고용이 예상치보다
크게 하회를 했습니다. 그래서
그러면서 최권 금리가 급락을 하게
됐고요. 그래서 비트코인 상승이
이루어졌고 달러 인덱스가 좀 줄어들어
달러 인덱스도 확 급락하는 모습
보여줬었습니다. 그래서 여러 가지가
비트코인을 상승하는데 굉장히 큰
도움이 됐었다라고 보면 될 거 같고
자 지금 여러 가지 그 온체인
데이터들을 같이 한번 참고해서 보고
있는데 어 여러 가지 데이터들을 보여
주는 거 봤을 때 유동성이나 어 마켓
메이커들 또는 이런 다양한 부분들이
지금 굉장히 매말라 있더라고요.
그래서 그런 부분들이 어제 비트코인
상승이 급등이 아니라 그냥 그
대체적인 상승 그리고 어 저항선을
막고 내려오는 그런 흐름이지 않았을까
하는 생각을 개인적으로 하고
있습니다. 어제부터 계속 제도적인
부분에 대해서 간단하게 안내를 드리고
있는 것 같습니다. 오른쪽 보시면
유럽에는 미카 법안이 서류터를
지배하고 있다게 설명드렸는데 미카
법안은 한 23년보다 추진이 돼서
계속해서이 유회 기간을 거치고 있었던
유럽의 법안입니다. 그래서 mar진
크립토스 reg레이션 이렇게 하는게
밀파라고 하는데요. 어 결국 간단하게
말씀드려서이
투자자들을 보호하는 것이 굉장히
강력해진 것입니다. 이런 거는 뭐
가장 자산을 하는 업자들이나 어
가장자산으로 사업하는 사람들에게는
굉장히 안 좋은 이슈겠죠. 왜냐면
그걸로 어 가장자한 투자들이 준 돈을
가지고 뭐 다른 투자를 한다던가 이런
식으로 원래 진행이 돼야 되는데 그래
돈이 돌지 않는 어 법안이 미카
법안이다라고 보시는게 가장 이해하기
쉬울 거 같고요. 어 가장 대표적인
어 조항으로 어 고객이 맡긴 자산을
일대일로 그냥 완벽하게 보관을 해야
된다라는게 어 미카 법안의 어
법안입니다. 그리고 어 고객이 바뀐
현금에서 한 60% 정도를 지역 은행
유럽의 지역은행 같은 은행들에게 어
수탁해야 된다라는 법안이 있는데요.
그래서 그럼에 따라서 어제 말씀드린
그 USDT 어 테더라는 테더의
경우에는 유럽에서 라이선스 아예
포기를 했습니다. 어 그래서 라이스
포기해서 어 오히려 우리가 어
USDT를 지금 유통을 하고 있는데
대규모 환매가 나왔는데 어 사람들이
다 그 어 지역 은행에 가서 돈
달라고 하면 어떡할 거냐? 약간
굉장히 큰 리스크다라고 하면서 어
유럽에 사업을 접은게 어 테더다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그러면 바로
힌트가 오실 수도 있는데 반사 수혜가
오는 거는 USD DC입니다.
그러니까 서클에 오히려 반사 수액가
올 수 있는 스테이블코인 시장에서는
서클의 반사 수액가 올 수 있는
법안이 미카 법안이다. 그래서 어
서클 관련된 그 리포트들 보시면 미카
관련된 얘기들이 계속해서 나올 건데
아 그건 이런 흐름에서 그렇게
됐구나. 그러니까 1등 사업자가 어
유럽에서 사업을 철수했구나라고 생각을
해 주시는게 가장 편할 것 같습니다.
또 하나 가장 큰 어 기업이
있는데요. 어 왼쪽 왼쪽 밑에 가장
밑에 보시면 바이낸스가 있습니다.
바이낸스도 유럽 쪽에서 지금 어
라이센스를 취득하지를 못해서 거의
사업을 약간 반 접은 상태입니다.
그래서이 사업자 사업을 취득하겠다라고
지금 발표해 놨지만 결국에 지금
유럽에서는 어 사업을 하지 못하고
있는 상황이다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데 바이낸스 말씀을 드린 이유는
바이낸스가 어 전 세계에서 가장 그
유저수도 많고 안에 수탁비에 있는
자산도 굉장히 많은 어 세계 최대
과장 자선 거래소이기 때문에 그런
부분들이 좀 걸리는 상황이다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 USDT와
바이낸스에는 공통점이 있습니다. 보통
둘 다 중국 홍콩계 자본이라는 점이
공통점인데요. 그런 부분들이 어 뭐
중국 자본이 불투명하다라는 건
아니지만 아무래도 지금 규제에 따르는
부분에 있어서는 바이낸스와 유치는
조금 더 덜 협조적이었다. 그래서 어
서클과 어 코인베이스 또는 뭐 다른
어 크라켄 같은 가상 자상자상 관련된
업자들은 어 지금 유럽 쪽에서 사업을
계속 할 수 있게 그 이거라도 좀
점유를 따올 수 있게 지금 노력을
굉장히 많이 해서 따온 상황이다라고이
정도 해석하시면 될 것 같습니다.
가장 밑에 두 개 말씀드리고 끝내면
될 거 같습니다. 어, 제가이 제목은
조금 그냥 손흥민 선수 인터뷰를 조금
마주 한 거인데요. 어제 그 오픈
스탠더드에서 어, 그 오픈라는
것을 스테이블 코인을 발행했다라고
하는 것을 제가 한번 말씀드린 적이
있습니다. 사실 이거 발행이
시작되지도 않았고 그냥 컨소시엄으로서
우리 하겠다라고 한 건데요. 어
서클은 어제 스탠더드티드라는
은행과 어 USDC를 유통할 수 있는
인프라 계약을 했다라고 해석을 하시면
될 거 같습니다. 어 그래서 어
스탠더드 찰셜은 G이라고 하는
은행권에 들어간다라고 하는데요. G은
그 어 미국에서 특별하게 관리하는
은행들 중에 하 냉질 리스트라고
합니다. 그래서 그 은행들 GB에
포함된 리스트들은 정말 어 너무 크기
때문에 망하면 안 되는 그런 리스크를
미국이지고 있기 때문에 어 미국이
특별적으로 이분들이 어 은행들은 어
지급 준비금의 비율를 좀 더 높여야
된다든가 아니면 어 국채를 사는
비율을 어 GC반에 강제해 준다는 거
따로 관리가 되게 되는 가장 큰 대형
은행들입니다. 그래서 그 중간 다리를
어 서클이 지금 USDC라는 스테이블
코인을 유통하기 위해서 뭐 코인
베이스도 사용하고 어 다양한 어
가장자 거래소들을 지금 활용을 하고
있었는데 스탠더드 샤티트가 지금
서클과 협력을 하면서 다른 기업들
다른 은행들이 USDC를 유통해서 쓸
수 있게 어 하는 그 중간 창구로
계약을 했다 협력을 했다라는 흐름으로
보시면 되기 때문에 오히려 오픈
USD 같은 어 회사들 입장에서는
그렇게 좋은 뉴스는 아니었다. 그리고
서클 서클 입장에서는 어제 굉장히 긴
해명이 있었긴 했지만 어 지금 제도권
안에서도 조금 USC 그러니까 어
스테이블 코인을 유통할 수 있는
채널을 확장을 했다. 어 그런
뉴스다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
오른쪽에는 트럼프에게 2025년에도
가상자산을 자산 증식을 했다라고 하는
뉴스를 제가 가져왔는데요.
로이터스에서 트럼프가 작년에
어 한 14억 달러 정도를 크립토
관련된 사업부에서 벌었다라고 하는
뉴스가 있었습니다. 트럼프가
공식적으로 오늘 부인을 하긴
했는데요. 어쨌든 실제로 그 어
대통령이랑 부통령에 대해서 자산 어
검사를 검사 조사를 한 번씩
하더라고요. 그 관련된 리포트가
나왔는데 그게 오른쪽 밑에 있는
표입니다. 오른쪽 밑에 보시면 뭐 어
USDC 방금 말씀드린 스테이블
코인도 있고요. 이더리움도 있고
그다음에 뭐 비트코인 같은 것도
있습니다. 그거를 가지고 있는
자산들이 굉장히 많다라는 것이
리포트가 실제로 됐고요. 어, 그리고
가장 밑에 있는게 조금 특이했던 건데
셀리브레이션 코인이라고 하는 것에서
로얄티를 거기서 로얄티를 어, 굉장히
많이 얻어간 것으로 파악이 됐습니다.
그래 트럼프 대통령이 물론 지금
가상자산의 이해 관계가 없다라고 하면
거짓말이다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
많은 어, 지금 이해 충돌 이슈들이
굉장히 많이 지금 진행이 되고
있습니다. 클리티 액트 같은 경우에도
그렇고 너네가 지금 클 어 크립토를
가지고 있는 상황에서 크립토 관련된
비를 미는게 말이 되냐 이런 충돌이
계속해서 있다라는게 이런 배경 속에서
그렇다라고 이해하시면 될 것
같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 오늘은 가상자산 주변에
어떤 제도와 기업들이 업데이트해 줄
수가 있는지를 잘 말씀해 주신 것
같습니다. 일부 [콧방귀] 여기서
마치도록 하겠습니다. 어 시장이
계속해서 조정 보이면서 걱정이 많으실
텐데요. 1부 함께 해 주신 여러분
2부에서 조금 더 자세한 내용
말씀드릴 수 있도록 하겠습니다. 과
함께 해주신 체턴 여러분
감사드립니다. 입니다.
[음악]
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
เฮ [음악]
[음악]
>> [음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정은
채슬리 투자 전문과 함께 채슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 3일 금요일 2부
순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자, 필반 지수가 이틀 동안 예,
급락을 했는데
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
음.
10년물 국제 금리가 좀 올라가기는
했는데
>> 전체적으로 시장
SMP 500은 또 보합이에요.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 그래서 약간 필반만 좀 영향을 좀
많이 받는데 아무래도 메타가
영향을 많이 준 거겠죠?
>> 예. 메타가 영향을 많이 줬고 메타를
메타발 이슈를 빌미로 해서
로테이션이나
또 레버리 청산이나 신형장고 청산
이런 부분 리밸런싱 요런 부분까지 좀
겹쳐서 일어나는 걸로 생각을 하고
있는데요. 그래서 이틀간 저님
말씀하셨듯이 누적 하락률은
11.4%입니다. 4%입니다. 근데
가만히 생각해 보면 어 필반 지수
베타도 높고 뭐 굉장히 많이 쏠려
있고 하기 때문에 아 이렇게 누적
하락률이 10% 이상 나타났던 적이
어 올해 꽤 있었거든요. 그 밑에
테이블을 보시면은
올해 3월에 그 일한 전쟁 있 그
있었을 때 어 3월 달 누적 하락률이
한 10% 정도 됐었고요. 그리고 어
5월 달에 또 금리하고 유가가 막
상승하면서 이틀에 한 6% 정도
하락했었고요.
그리고 어 6월 달 초에 금리하고
스페이스 X 상장 뭐 이러저런 이슈로
인해서 이틀 만에 12%가 하락을
했었습니다. 그리고음
6월 어 중순쯤에 뭐 단기 과일
밸류에이션 부담해서 뭐 이유는
없었는데 굳이 이유를 붙이자면 요런
이슈를 위해서 1.9%가
하락했었고요. 그리고
상반기 마치고 어 7월 1일 2 단이
거래일 동안에 11.4%가 4%가
하락을 했습니다. 그래서 어 메타발
뭐 인형 인프라 논란이 빌미가 되면서
혹시라도 케펙스가 축소되 있는 거
아닌가 요런 우려들 플러스 저는 주가
과열 그리고 신용 장고 높은 상황에서
사익 실현 및 리밸런싱 수요
섹터 확산 그리고
그런 부분들이 좀 같이 어 누적 그
그 누적되면서 어 나온 하락이 아닌가
싶습니다. 그래서 어 첫날 하락
쪽에서 좀 과잉 반응 아닌가 싶었는데
하락이 한번 더 세게 나왔다고 보시면
될 거 같고요.
예 밑에 그 필반 지수 EPS하고 P
보시면은 P 멀티플이 23.65배까지
65배까지
어 낮아졌고요. 어 EPS는
변함이 없었습니다.
미즈오에서 관련 코멘트를 냈는데 저도
대체로 좀 동의하는 편인데 그 최근에
나오는 아이비들의
그 코멘트를 전부 다 계속해서 검토해
봤는데 토는 뭐 비슷합니다.
어 일단음 미조에서 나온 거는
블룸버그가 보도한 메타의 클라우드
컴퓨팅 용량 직접 판매 검토는 어
단기 사업화 신호도 투자 둔화 신호도
아니라는 판단을 하고 있고 메타의
계획은 단지 플랜 B의 성격으로
이해하는게 맞다라고 어 미주에서는
보고 있습니다. 인프라 투자의 그
ROI 실현 경로는 두 가지인데 자체
AI 제품으로 수익하거나 용량을
임대하는 것이고 어 메타의 경우 어
투자자 대부분이 그 AI 투자에
대해서 신뢰할 만한 수익과 경로를
그리지 못한 상황이라서 이번 검토를
어떤 방식으로든 ROI를 높이겠다는
의지 표현으로 해석해야 될 것이라고
어 판단을 하고 있고요.
어제 그 블룸버그 관에서 나온 어
메타의 어떤 반응 이게 뭐 타운
미팅인가 어디에서 나온 그 마크
저커버그의 어 코멘트라고 하는데 어
AI 에이전트를 개발하고 있었지만
기대만큼 진전 없었다라고 얘기를 하고
있고 마크업 커버가 타운을 미팅에서
밝힌 바에 따르면 지난 4개월간 AI
에이전트 개발이 기대했던 방식으로
가수화되지 않았고
아 또한 회사 조직 예편이 매끄럽게
진행되지 못했으며 새 조직 구조에서
기대했던 투자들들이 아직 결실을 맺지
못하고 있다. 이런 코멘트로 봐서
내부적으로 좀 AI 투자에 대한
효익에 대해서
고민이 있었을 것 같고 그 고민
하에서
이런 그 플랜비 B 성격에 계획이
발표된 거 아닌가라는 생각입니다.
그래서이
부분이 그 AI의 방향성이나 아
케펙스 축소나 뭐 이런 부분으로
[콧방귀] 이어지기는 좀 어렵다는
생각이고요. 그리고
그이
것을 빌미로 해서 어 최근에 그
상반기 동안 한 100% 이상 올랐던
필반 지수 전반에 어 매물이 나왔던
거 아닌가 싶습니다. 그래서 어 요런
그 하락들이 어 베타가 그 큰음 필반
지수에 좀 자주 나타나는 상황이고 또
최근에 솔림도 어 상당히 강했고
굉장히 그 펀드 메이저 서베이를
통해서 보더라도
어 매매가 상당히 좀 어 거친 어
이런 부분들이 있었기 때문에 어 이번
11.4% % 이틀 동안 하락한 거는
이전에 하락하고는 그 이유는 좀
다르지만 어 결과적으로 봤을 때 어이
논란 자체가 좀 완화되면서 다시
보건되지 않을까라고 생각을 하는데 아
그러기 위해서는 어 실적이라든지
빅테크들의 그 케펙스에 대한
가이던스에 대한 확인 요런 부분들이
어 필요하지 않을까라고 생각을
입니다.
그래서 어제도 보면은 필반 지수의
종목들이 두 자리 지수 하락한 것들도
많고 상승한
종목들은 없었습니다. 그래서
전반적으로 기대적인 어 매도가
한꺼번에 어 나오지 않았나라고 생각을
하고 있고요.
11% 정도 이렇게 하락을 두 자릿수
단기에 하락을 했기 때문에어요
정도 이전에 하락 어 폭에 어 비춰
볼 때 어 그 외부적인 요인에 의해서
어 하락한 부분들이요 정도 빠지면은
좀 반등하는 어 그런 패턴이 나왔기
때문에 [콧방귀] 어 저는 여기에서
좀 반등이 있지 않을까라고 생각을
합니다.
6월 고용 지표가 어제 나왔는데
이농업 고용자수가 57,000명
증가했습니다. 전월에
12만9,000명으로
어 그 증가가 됐었는데 전원에 비해서
좀 작았고요. 어 전문 사무직이
36천 그리고 서해 복지 지원이
25천 헬스케어가 22,000 레저
적격이 61이
줄었습니다. 레저 접격이 어 지난
달에 조금 많았었는데 요쪽이 좀 준
것이 전반적으로 그 비농욱 고용자수가
전널 대비 좀 증각폭이 낮았던 거
같고요. 실험률은 4.2%가 나왔는데
어 전월에 4.3%였습니다.
어 보니까 채형도 적었고 해고도
적었음을 좀 시사하는 부분이 있는데
어 경제 활동 참가율이 어
61.5%에 5%에 불과했고요. 어
5월에 61.8%였습니다.
8%였습니다. 그래서 경제 활동
참가율이 줄어든 것을 감안해 봤을 때
채형도 적었고 백고도 적었음을
시사하는 어 실험률이 아닐까라고
생각합니다. 그래서 브레이크 이은
un 언임인 이런 부분들이 있는데
요런 부분들이 좀 얇아지는 과정에서
나온 실험률 아닌가 싶습니다.
그래서 이제 어 금리 정책이 사실
어떻게 되고 물가가이 부분이
어떻게 어 영향을 받았나이 부분
때문에 어떻게 영향을 받았나 요런
것들을 좀 어 체크를 해 봤는데
클리블랜드 연원에서 계속 그 6월하고
7월 CPI하고 PC 관련된 어 물가
업데이트를 해 주는데 7월 2일 날
그 업데이트가 된 것이기 때문에
어 어제 바로 좀 업데이트가 됐을
거로 생각을 하는데 어 CPI가 어
이번 달 중순쯤에 어 나올 거고요.
PC가 아 7월 30일쯤에 나올 건데
일단 5월에 CPI가 헤드라인
기준으로 4.2%가 나왔는데 얼마
전에 그 블룸버그나
그 클리블랜드 연원에서 한 4.0%
정도를 어 6월에 예상을 했었는데
6월 CPI가 3.9%로 9%로 조금
더 낮아질 걸로 어 시장하고
클리블랜드 연원에서
추정을 하고 있고요. 7월 CPI가
3.49% 3.5% 정도로 어 좀 더
낮아질 걸로 보고 있습니다. 그리고
PC 같은 경우는 5월 PC가
4.1% 그리고
6월이 어 3.9% 그리고 7월이
3.7% 코어 PC 같은 경우는
3.4 3.43 3.447로 47로
어 코어 [콧방귀] 같은 경우는 잘
안 떨어질 걸로 어 시장에서는 좀
보고 있는 상황입니다. 그래서 어
어제
고용 지표 나오고 비농업 고용자수가
생각보다 좀 낮아서 그랬는지 몰라도
어 페드워치에서 그 추정하는
7월 29일 열리는 그 FMG에서의
동결 가능성은 82.4%로
확인이 되고요. 일주일 전에
66.3%에서 3%에서 어 좀 증가가
됐습니다. 그래서 그 매크로 지표 어
나오는 거에 따라서
그이 그 가능성 자체는 어 변할 수
있고요. 어 지금까지 어 나온 지표로
어 봤을 때 82.4% 4% 지금
현재 어 7월 29일 FMC에서 동결
가능성을 좀 높여 준 상황입니다.
그리고 어제 저문님이 말씀하신 그
AI 활용도에 대해서 어 기사 검색을
좀 해 봤는데이 기사 자체가 이제
맞는지 모르겠습니다. 근데 어 벤처
비트에서 나온 리서치 기관인데
그 자료에 따르면 2026년 5월
8일 한 두 달 전에 조사된 내용 그
나온 자료에 따르면 기업들의 AI
지출 특히 이제 GPU에 지출하는
거가
어 활용률이 5%에 불과하다. 아
이런 기사가 있었습니다. 그래서 어이
기사에 따르면 어 가트너가 기업
관계자들 그니까 1월에 53명 그리고
2월에 39명을 통해서음
추정해 본 결과 기업들의 AI 지출
대비 평균 활용률은 5%에
불과하다라는
결론을 내렸는데 어 그 이유가 어
데이터 통합 미읍 그리고 내부 준비
부족 그리고 회사 규정 미 등에 다른
것이라고 어 얘기를 하고 있고요.
근데 표본 자체가 50 기업 관계자들
50명한 40명 수중이라서 어 조금
어 그렇긴 한데 어쨌든 그 일부
기업들 어의 그 AI 활용도 그러니까
GPU를 확보해 놓고 그 GPU를
어떻게 써야 될지 몰라서 좀 잘 못
쓰는 경우를
갖다가 어
치사하는 어떤 글이라고 어 볼 수
있을 것 같고 어 현재
하이퍼스케일러들하고 어 프렌티어 랩
그리고 어 소비자 기업단에서 어
실제로 소비자 기업 쪽에서 프런티어
랩 오픈 AI나 뭐 어 엔트로픽이나
구글의 재미나이나 뭐 이런 것들을
쓰는 부분하고 그리고 기업단에서 어
그 GPU를 어 배열을 하거나 실제로
어 확보해서 쓰거나 하는 부분들은 어
하이퍼 프스케일러 쪽이 될 거 같은데
어 이쪽 부분에서의 활용도가
생각보다 미진하다. 그 지출대이
미진하다. 어 요런 부분들을 좀
시사한 어 거가 아닌가 싶습니다.
[콧방귀] 이상입니다.
>> 우리 문성무님이 보시에는 어때요?
일단 엔터프라이즈의 그 투자가 시작이
된 거 같긴 한데 아직 자체 그 모델
세팅이 좀 미진한 느낌 좀 없잖아
있는 거 같아요. 사 놓고도 좀 안
쓰는 느낌. 그래서 일단은 지금
급한대로 클라우드에 있는 여기서 선도
모델들을 쓰고 있는 거 같습니다.
저커버그가 좀 어떤 사람인지에 대해서
알지?
>> 저크버그가 굉장히 공격적고 예.
도전적이고
>> 맞아요.
>> 예. 그런 사람이고 이전에 어
메타버스인가 어 이거 하려고 잔뜩 그
비용 지출을 했다가 어 나중에 좀 그
효과가 안 나니까 어 비용을 좀
줄이는
>> 그리고 조직을 효율화 하는 그런
사례들이 있었습니다.
>> 예.
정확하게 저도 똑같은 생각을 하고
있고
어젯밤에도 이제 아들 똑같은 얘기를
좀 해 줬는데요.이 저커버그가 보면
굉장히 공격적이고
먼저 치고 나가는 스타일이라는 거죠.
치고 나가는 스타일이라서 21년도
하반기에이 메타버스이
네티브 시장을 만든 것도음
뭐 만들었다기보 그때 그걸 이제 좀
더 네러티브를 강화시켰던게
페이스북이었는데 우리 앞으로이
세상이야
그러면서 이름도 메타로 바꾸고
>> 예
>> 그때
어 그냥 초 초보 프로그래머
주니어 프로그래머를 막 30만 불에
막 내려오고 막 그래서 인건비 상정을
야기시키기로 했고 그쪽으로 막
질러댔었는데
어 그전에 보면 그 벌출 VR 기계
있잖아요. 그 VR 기기도 벌써
메타가 옛날에 2011년인가
12년도에
그걸 오큘러스를 1 1조 4천억니까
뭐 그렇게
벌써 그게 한 15년 전에
인수했어요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 예.
어떤 그런 혁신적인 거에 굉장히
빠르게 공격적으로 해하는 스타일인데
그것도 오큘러스도 뭐 VR 그 별로
아직까지도 15년이 지났는데 별 볼
일은 없는데 어 메타버스도
마찬가지였죠. 예.
>> 막 질러다가 그것 때문에 22년도에
주가가 한 75% 빠지거든요.
>> 원래 페이스북의 생태계에서는
안정적으로 캐시카운 역할로
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 돈이 딱딱 나오죠. 광고 또 그렇고.
>> 음. 근데 메타상으로 간다고 하면서
막 질러대 그쪽에서 뭐 밑빠진 독이
질질줄질 흘러내려가고
흘러나오고 그리고 뭔가 성과가 당장
보이는 걸 만들기가 애매한 상황이
되자 그러자 22년도에 하여튼 주가
박살하고 23년 언저리에서
아 이거 내가 좀 너무 빨 빨빨랐던
거 같아. 예. 그러면서 그 사업보
확 축소해 [콧방귀] 버리고
>> 그러면서 다시 주가가 회복하고
회복하면서 훨씬 이제 많이 올라왔죠.
저 그래서 저커버그가 항상 좀
빠르다.
>> 예. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 그쪽 생택에 있는 사람들의 얘기를
보면 저거보가 항상 빠르다. 그래서
어떻게 보면 GPU 제일 많이 지출한
회사가 메타랑 마이크로소프트
아니었습니까? 23년 24년도에 그때
GPU 가장 많이 지은게 네터
마이크로 그랬잖아요. 그죠?
>> 그리고 그 밑으로 내려가다 보면 뭐
알리바도 요만큼 했었는데
>> 그래서 제일 빨리 지은 것도 맞아요.
제일 빨리 질렀고 지금 제일 빨리 야
그런데이 다 질러놨는데 뭐야? 왜
이렇게 활용을 못 하고 있어?
그러면서 좀 전에 지금 댓글에도
나오지만
>> 어 중국 업체 이게 뭐죠? 마누스
AI
박사 마누스 AI라고 하네. 메타에서
아 중국계 AI 아 그
메타 인수하려고 했는데 중부 정부가
그냥 하지 말라고 그냥 팔지 말라고
그렇게 했잖아요. 그
>> 아 그게 중국 정부가 가지 말라고
>> 예 중국 정부가 가지 말라고
그랬어요. 그래서 메타에서 마누스를
인수를 해 주신데 중국 정부에서
문제고
얼마 전까지만 해도 인스타에서
인사이트라는 메뉴에서 마우스 AI를
사용해 보라는 제한이 있었다가 최근에
없어졌다고
그래서 그걸 막 좀 유틸라이제이션
하기 위해서 안쓰든 뭐든 그리고 저도
오늘 보는데 그 구글 창에 여러 개
뭐 띄워져 있는데 제일 오른쪽
상단에는 재미
물어보세요. 그렇게 돼 있더라고요.
>> 그러니까 좀 많이 써라. 어. 어.
그런 느낌이 좀 드는 부분이에요.
그래서 약간 우리가이 부분을 완전히
무시할 것도 아닌 거 같다 보니까.
>> 네.
>> 그리고 제가 거적 들었던 얘기가이
5%였었거든요.
>> 예.
AI 기업들 AI 대비 활용률이
5%에 불가다. 뭐 요런 얘기도 그런
생각이고 여기 이제 기사에 나왔던
거요.
아무튼 그 AI 최전방에 있는
사람들의 이야기를 계속 듣고 있는데
>> 어 석달 전에 들었던 얘기가
앤스록식이 이제 완전히 치고
나옵니다. 전문가 영역에서는 그
얘기도 들었고 근데 이번에들은 얘기가
막 질러됐는데 어 유틸라이제이션
왜 이래 뭐 아니 질러야 된 데서 다
질러놨는데
왜
>> 활용을 왜 왜 이렇게 활용을 못 하고
있는 거야
>> 그 방안을 광고해 봐라
>> 요런게 최근의 일이에요.
>> 예 맞습니다.
>> 얘기라고 그러더라고요.
그 부분은 어 계속 우리가 좀 체크를
해 보시고요.
전체적인 시장은
어 필반 빠졌지 어
>> 여기 52주 신고가 보면 헬스케어
종목들이 많아지고 있습니다. 하고
볼텍스
FB하고
기타
파이낸셜 쪽에서도 이자
>> 예
>> 밑에가 올스테이트예요.
예. 올스테이트
>> 이거는 보험회사가
>> 아 잘 안 봤더
>> 보험회사
>> 그리고 그 크라우드 스트라이크가
50회주 신고가에 올라 있더라고
>> 팔로터 네트워크스로
보안쪽 관련해서 계속 신했습니다.
그래서 유리프로파를 발표할 때 IT
측에서 또 클라우드 스트라이크나 이런
보안 쪽은 또
>> 음
>> 나쁘지 않 그런 모습을 보여주고
어 유가도 70% 이하로 빠지고
어 실험토 사점이 다 좋게 나왔는데
>> 딱 하나요 국제 10년물 아 요게
자꾸 4.48에서 48에서 떨어지고
있어 가지고요
>> 부분만 조금 신경 써요. 또 나머지는
크게 시장 전체적으로
>> 나쁜 거는 없어 보이고 SP 500
이퀄트가 어제는 0.7이나 7
올라요. 그러니까 밑단에 좀
중세용주단에서는 좀 올라갔다는
얘기죠.
>> 그렇습니다. 그 종목이나 섹터가 어
IT 반도체 쪽 빼고 다른 쪽으로
확산이 되면서 어 이퀄레이트 지수가
상대적으로 많이 오는 거 같습니다.
예.
>> MSSI 사우스코리아 ETF는
2.89%.
자, 그러면 국내 진행으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
[웃음]
전일 시작 말씀드리겠습니다.
호스피 지수 전일 급락세를
보였는데요. 7.8% 7.8% 가량
큰 폭의 하락률을 기록을 했습니다.
지수가 7,800포인트까지
내려온 상황이고요. 지금 5거릴
기준으로도 지수가 14%가 하락하면서
최근 몇 거래일간의 납폭이 상당히
크게 나타나고 있습니다. 그리고
코스닥 쪽이 최근에 좀 올라가나
싶었는데 전일장에서는 6.7% 7%
또다시 좀 크게 하락하는
모습이었고요. 수급적으로 봐 주시면
개인 투자자가 6조 2천억 정도
매수를 했습니다. 반면에 외인들의
매도는 여전히 지속돼서 나오고 있는데
4조 4천억 가량 매도가 나왔습니다.
기관에서는 2조대 매도가 나오면서
[콧방귀] 대체로 외국인의 매도가 좀
강하면 기관에서도 좀 받아주는 모습이
나왔었는데 전일장에서는
동반에서 좀 매도하는 모습이었고요.
반면에 외인 선물은 매수세가 이거
연속 좀 강하게 유입이 되는데요.
대체로 다 장 막판에 매수를
확하더라고요. 그래서 외국인들의 선물
움직 플러스권을 유지하고 있는 거
같습니다. 아래 투자자별 매매
동향으로 가서 보면 저일 외국인
투자자가 매수한 종목은 삼성전자
우선주, 리노공업, 현대차,
DBI텍, LG 전자 이오테크,
ISC 등을 매수했고요. 반면 매도
쪽에는 SK하이닉스 삼성전자, SK
스퀘어 삼성전기, LS1렉 하락 오션
등을 매도하면서 대용 반도체 두 종목
합산에서 한 3조 정도 매도가 나왔던
거 같습니다. 기간 매수에는 SK
스퀘어, KB금융, 신한 지주, 한
에로스페이스, 이수페타, 어,
현대차, 하이브 등을 매수했고요.
기관 매도에는 SK 하이닉스 3조
매도했습니다. 기관 쪽에서 하이닉스에
대한 매도가 좀 강했고요. 그 외에는
삼성전자, 리노, 나머지
ETF였습니다. [목을 가다듬음]
52주 신고가 종목은 뭐 열 종목
정도로 늘어났다가 다시 훅
내려앉았는데네
종목밖에 안 나왔습니다. 코스피에서
한국 콜마 그리고 사무 개발이
신고가였고요. 코스닥에서 나마토건,
광진, 실업이 신고가였습니다. 확실히
코스피의 그 한국 콜마가 최근에 좀
주가가 상당히 강하더라고요. 유럽에서
지금 폭염도 좀 일어나고 있고
독일 기준으로 최근에 좀 굉장히
덥다고 하는데 거기 에어컨도 인율이
한 자리 수라고 하더라고요. 처음인데
뭐 날씨가 그렇게 덥지 않은
>> 나라인지 뭐 그랬다고 하는데 뭐 유럽
쪽이 워낙 지금 덥다 보니까 또이
선크림 계열의 회사들이 좀 주목을
받는 거 같습니다.
날이 폭염인데
왜 선크림 잘 팔리지?
아 근데 어 더운데
더운데 거기는 에어컨이 보급률이
거니까 얼마 안 되더라고. 우리나라랑
일본이 뭐 한 80% 이상 되는 거
같아요. 음. 의외로 유력적이고
>> 그리고
그래서 집에 못 있는구나. 너무
더워서. 뭐 차에서 산다고도 하고 막
우리는 겨우면 오히려 사무실이나 집이
집에서 안 나가는데 거기는 집에 있을
수가 없는 상황입니다.
우리 최민턴 분들 중에 또 독일이나
유럽에 또 계신 분들 계시니까 그쪽
상황 좀 전해 주시고 자 외국인이
하이닉스랑 삼성전자만 두 개 합쳐서
3조 1천억 정도가 기관이 어제
하이닉스만 3조라도네
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 어제는 기관인
쌍거리
매도했네.
자, 주기업 동 한번 쭉 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 요제 반도체 섹터 먼저 보면 좀
험악한 하루였는데요. 삼성전자가 9%
가량 급락세를 보였고 하이닉스가
약 15% 급락이 나왔습니다. 장
막판들어서 더 강하게
>> 좀 밀렸었던 거 같고요. 그래서 지금
뭐 PR로 메모리 반도체를 보진
않지만 한 일곱배까지 하이닉스가
올라왔다가 5.700까지 내려온
상황입니다.
어 소부장 종목들 봐 주시면 한미
반도체도 어제 11% 급락을
보였고요. HPSP 그리고 원익
IPS 심택
뭐 SNS텍 대덕전자 솔브레인 뭐
소재나 기판 장비 대체로 한 10%가
평균적인 하락률이고 좀 많게 빠진
종목들은 20% 이상 하락하는
종목들도 좀 많이 나왔던 거
같습니다. 최근에 기판 쪽에서 들리는
얘기로는 지금 메모리 업체들이 기판
업체들에 대한 가격 인하를 좀
압박하고 있다. 뭐 이런 이야기가
있기는 한데 연고님들 코멘트 보면
가능성은 좀 적지 않나? 이런
부정적인 이야기를 하시더라고요.
ITS 섹터 봐 주시면 삼성 전기의
주가도 굉장히 부진했습니다.
전일장의 12% 급락세를 보였고요.
아래 LG 이노텍이나 뭐 BH 모바일
밸류체인이 있는 기업들도
약세였습니다.
반면에 플랫폼 쪽이 시장 대비 굉장히
좋았는데요. 네이버가 1.3,
카카오가 1.3%, 3% 카카오
뱅크도 한 5% 가량 상승하면서 8%
더 나쁘지 않았습니다.
어제 니케이 지수 2.5% 하락했는데
역시나 여기도 반도체가 안
좋았습니다. 로표 일렉트론닉이
7.4타가 8.5 하고 디스코 9%
2비된 오트반도 9%대의 하락률을
기록하면서 일본 증시에서도 반도체
기판 쪽이나 뭐 MLCC 장비 대체로
안 좋았습니다. 어제 자동차 섹터는
시장 대비론 그래도 괜찮았습니다. 어
좀 선재적으로 많이 빠졌던 영향도
있었던 거 같고요. 현대차가 1%
하락했고 모비스나 뭐 오토에버도
약세였습니다.
어 소비제 섹터 봐 주시면 생건이
3.8 아모레가 5% 상승했고요.
코스메카 코리아의 주가가 최근에
상당히 강한데 전일장에서도 한 4%
이상의 상승률을 기록했습니다.
피후 미용 기기는 상대적으로 어제는
좀 약했습니다. 클래시스 파마 휴젤
AP했고요.
아래 내려가서 보면 영업 무역이
12% 가량 급등하면서 모처럼 의류
쪽도 좋은 모습이었고요. 농심이 6%
가량 급등세를 보였습니다. 농심도
반등이 좀 나오는 모습이었고 어제
KTNG도 3.5%
상승 마감했습니다. 에카점 체인은
그저께 좀 올랐다가 어젯장에서 좀
조정이 또 나오는 모습이었고요.
저선감미 기타 섹터 봐 주시면 어제
하나 오션을 제외한 현대 중공업이나
하나 엔진은 대체로 약세였습니다.
확실히 현대 중공이나 하는 엔진은
지금 AI 밸류 체인에 어느 정도
엮겨 있다라고도 좀 볼 수가 있기
때문에 반도체 [콧방귀] 하락 영향을
조금 받지 않았나라는 생각이 들고요.
아래 철강이나 화학 섹터 보합 정도
유지하면서 시장 대비론 좀 변조한
모습 나타났습니다.
어 아래 방산주들 흐름을 보면 최근에
좀 괜찮은 거 같습니다. 하나로가
2.3% 올랐고요. 현대 로템이 4%
가량 상승세를 보였습니다.
어젯장에서도 아, 간밤에 라인 메탈의
주가가 한 6% 가량 올라갔더라고요.
그리고 글로벌 방산 디펜스 ETF가
최근에 흐름이 좋은데
>> 어장에서도 좀 많이 올라가는 흐름이
>> 나타난 걸로 봐서는 오늘도 좀 방산
업체 주가 기대해 볼 만 하지
않나라는 생각이 들고 아래 바이오섹터
봐 주시면 셀트리온이 1.2% 2%
가량 상승 마감했고요.
[콧방귀] 방금 셀트리온 실적 발표가
나왔는데 어닝 서프라이즈를
기록했습니다.
>> 음. 실적이 굉장히 좀 좋게 나온
걸로 봐서는 NXT에서 좀 강한 거
같고요. 그리고 아래 코스닥 바이오
종목들 봐 주시면 그렇게 좋지
않았지만 시장 대비로는 그래도 나쁘진
않았던 거 같습니다. 테오젠이나 AB
바이오 패트론 약세였고요.
최근에 또 은행주들의 주가름이
좋습니다. KB이 4%가랑 상승
마감했고 증권주 조금 반등하나
싶었는데 전장에서는 좀 약세로
마감했습니다. 그 엔터 쪽이 좀
상당히 강합니다. 4.6 올랐고 GP
4.3, SM량
상승하면서 확실히 밸류 메리트가 있다
보니 수급이 소비제 쪽으로 들어올 때
엔터 쪽으로도 들어오는 움직임이
나타나는 거 같고요. 변합기 쪽은 좀
어제 아쉬웠는데요. 현대 일렉트릭이
1조 2천억 가량의 수주 공시가
있었어요.
>> 음. 근데 주가가 한 5% 이상
수주공시 나오고 올라가다가 확실히
여기도 AI 밸류체인에 엮겨 있다
보니 그대로 좀 막고 내려오는 모습이
나타나면서 LS 1렉 같은 종목도
10% 가량 급락세를 보였고
효성중공업도 약세였습니다.
자 주중 기업들 동명을 쭉
살펴봤고요.
리포트를 가져오셨는데 조금 전에도
위에 보다 보니까 어 화장품의 시대가
다시 돌아 도래했나 약간 이런 느낌을
받는데
화장품 아모리 퍼시픽 리포트
가져오셨다. 요보 번호 연구원 코스x
Y
30%
플러스 프라임데이 보조
그걸 다 더했는데도 밸류는 17배
너무 싼 거 아니야?요 약간 요런
요양증인가요?네 네, 맞습니다. 내용
자체에서 뭐 너무 싸다 뭐이 정도의
이야기 하진 않았는데 밸류 메리트가
좀 있는 구간이다 정도 코멘트했던 거
같습니다. 2분기 실적이 컨센 정도
나올 것으로 보고 있는데요. 어,
매출이 1조 1천억, 영업이 약
1,억 정도 나오면서 영업 이익이
그래도 YY로 33% 정도 증가할
것으로 추정을 했습니다. 시장 컨센
정도 나올 것으로 보는 거 같고요.
국내외 코r 매출 성률이 기존 추정을
상여하는 실적을 기록할 것으로 본다.
그래서 국내에서는 yy로 어 미드
싱글 디에서 좀 하이 싱글 디지으로
올라갈 것으로 보고 있고요. 코스렉스
자체는 YY 20에서 한 30%
정도로 올라갈 것 같다라고 추정을
했습니다. 어 국내 매출행및 영업
이익은 각각 6조원
그리 그리고 6,억 원 그리고 어
영업 이익은 540억 전망을
했는데요. 어 채널 별로는 이커머스
10% 그리고 멀티브랜드 쇼이 15%
백화점이 로우 싱글 디지 면세가
하이싱글 디지 증가하면서 여전히
이커머스 및 MBS 채널 중심 성장이
이어나갈 것으로 보고 있습니다.
그래서 인바운드조에 따라 백화점이나
연세점 채널 예상 대비 좀 긍정적인
성과를 기록할 것으로 보고 있고요.
수익성은 회계연도 마감에 따른
인센티브 비용 반영 등으로 Q로는 좀
감소할 수 있다. 그리고 인건비
감소나 할인율 축소등으로 YY 개선
흐름은 그래도 좀 지속적으로 나타나지
않을까라고 긍정적인 돈으로 이야기를
했고요. 해외 쪽 이야기도 했는데
해외 매출이 4,900억 그리고 영업
이익이 한 500억 정도 나올 것으로
보면서 해외 쪽의 회복이 좀 강한 거
같습니다. YY 51% 나올 것으로
추정을 했고요. 중국은 서라 오프라인
효율하로 YY로 20% 감소했지만
수익성은 bep 흐름 유지할 것으로
보고 있고 미주 쪽은 YY 20%
정도 성장했을 것으로 전망을
했습니다. 어 설환수가 좀 입점을
확대하고 있다라고 하고요.
이니스프리나 에스트라 성장으로 본업
성장도 주도 중이라고 합니다.
라네즈는 2분기 Y와Y 플랫타겠지만
아마존 프라임데이 행사 오조로
QQ로는 그래도 견조한 성장 기록할
것으로 보고 있습니다. 이분기 아마존
주요 SKU는 QQ 성장률은 립클로
이밤 73% 그리고 립슬만 24%
글레이즈 세럼이 79%
증가하면서 좀 견조했다라고 하고요.
일리윤도 세럼 마이드 크림 이쪽도 좀
140% 증가하면서 포실적을 기록했을
것으로 추정했습니다. 그리 그리고
EMA의 지역도 좀 나쁘지 않을
것으로 보고 있고요. 서구성 수익성은
인센티브 비용 및 신규 브랜드 마케팅
투자로 QQ론 좀 감소할 것으로
전망을 했고요. 코스렉스 매출이 좀
잘 나올 것으로 추정이 되고 있는데
유럽에서 YY 50% 고성장하는
가운데 미주에서도 1분기부터 YOY
20%대 증가 흐름을 기록 중이라고
합니다. 유럽에서는 선케어 제품이
긍정적인 것으로 파악이 된다라고 하고
2분기 주 SKU QQ 성장률은
스네일 뮤신 세럼 펩타이드 아이패치
펩타이드 세럼 등이 YY로 큰 폭으로
성상했을 것으로 추정을 했고요. 어
투자액기는 바이 타겟 프라이스 18만
원으로 유시를 했습니다. 아마존
프라임데이에서 라네즈 기준 히어로
SKU가 아마존 BT 탑 100에 세
개에 진입했다라고 하고요. 1 2윤과
코사렉스도 진입을 했다라고 합니다.
그래서 이익도 YY로 30% 이상
증가하는 호실적을 기록할 것으로
추정되는 가운데 밸류는 과거 대비
훨씬 매력도가 높아진 상황이다. 현재
주가는 12월 포워드 멀티플 17배
불과하기 때문에 역대 최저 수준의
밸류로 거래되고 있어서 밸류 웨리트가
굉장히 좀 높아진 구간이 아니냐
의견을 제시해 주셨습니다.
어 아래표로 내려가서 보면 올해
연간실적 추정을 보면요.
연간으로 매출 4조 6,억 정도 나올
것으로
추정을 한 거 같고요. 내려가서 영업
이익 단으로 보면 4,800억 가량
추정이 되고 있습니다. 국내 쪽이
그래도 최근에 좀 좋은 거 같은데요.
아모래퍼시픽의
화장품들도 올리브형이나 이런 쪽에
아까 말씀드린 MBS 채널에 입점들을
많이 해 있는데 외국인 관광객들이
들어와서 다이소 올리브형 이런 쪽으로
많이 들어가잖아요. 그리고 백화점도
방문을 많이 하다 보니 뭐
아모래퍼시픽에 고가장품은 또 백화점
가서 사고 LG생건의 고가화장품 이런
거는 백화점 면세 채널 가서 산다라고
보면 또 이런 중적가 화장품들은
올리브형 같은데 외국인들이 방문해서
많이
구매를 하고 있기 때문에 국내 실적이
그래도 나쁘지 않게 올라가는 흐름이
관찰이 되고 있는 거 같습니다.
[기침][목을 가다듬음]
그리고 오른쪽 차트는 어 아무래
퍼시픽의 EPS와 P 밸루에이션
추인데요. 2019년도부터 나오는
자료인데 지금 EPS 추정치는
좀 올라가고 있는데 PR은 계속
내려가고 있는 상황이거든요.
>> 하얀색이 EPS다. 그죠?
>> 네. 네. 맞습니다. 음. PS
추정치는 나쁘지 않은 흐름에도
불구하고 최근에 반도체 쪽으로 수급이
쏠려가다 보니 소비제가 좀 소외되어
왔었는데이 밸류에이션이 역사적 저점
수준에 있기 때문에 역사적 저점이
있는데 실적은 나쁘지 않은
상황이에요. 그렇기 때문에 어
평균적으로만 올라간다라고 봐도 한 뭐
20배 정도까지는 업사이드가
밸류 트레인 관점으로도 열려 있다
생각이이 표를 보면서 좀
들었습니다.데이
근데이 차이 차트를 보면서 드는
생각은 투자자 입장에서는
앞전에도 EPS가 이제 위로 쫙
올라갔다가 또 박살 또 올라갔다가
다시 떨어지고
>> 그게 약간 양치기 소년 몇 번
됐었잖아요.
>> 몇 년째 양치기 소년하고 있었잖아.
7년째 양치기 소년하고 있냐? 그
>> 10년
>> 10년 거의 7년 다리가네.
>> 그러니까 못 믿는 거지.
그래서 이게 EPS가 올라오면서
주가도 같이 탄탄하게 올라가서 뭐 저
PER이 안 떨어지는데
똑똑해 가지고 EPS가 쫙 올라갔는데
PR 떨어져 버리잖아요.이
이익이 지속 가능하지 않는다고 시장이
판단하고 때려 버리는 거지.
안 올라오는
그래서 바튼이 맞았어. 다시
이에서부터 꺾였어. 그러고 나서 지금
또 올라가다가
꺾이고 한데 저점은 이제 높아지는
모습인데 이번에 지금 EPS가
돌아서고 있는데 이번에는 진짠가 근데
하도 많이 저거 해 놓으니까 못 믿는
거죠.
근데 제가 생각했을 땐 좀 이전과는
다른 게
>> 2021년에
이제 LG 생활 건강 아모래 퍼시픽의
주가가 상당히 좋았었잖아요. 그외는
이제 화장품 산업의 트렌드가 좀
바뀌면서 어 온라인 쇼핑 위주에 하는
기업들 그리고 마케팅을 잘하는
기업들이 이제 올라가다 보니 어쩔 수
없이 실적도 굉장히 꺾였고 멀티플
디레이팅까지 나타났었다가 24년도부터
24년 중반까지 또 EPS 추정치가
급격하게 올라갔잖아요.
>> 저때 기억해 보면 코스렉스를
인수하면서 미국 쪽 실적이 한 두 세
분 정도 되게 좋게 나왔었어요.
그래서 어 이게 지속 가능하보다
잘 인수했구나 싶었는데 미국 쪽에
성장이 확 꺾이면서 예상했던 거보다
안 나오면서 EPS가 쭉 내려왔고
밸루에이션도 다시 한번 이제 아까
말씀하신 대로 또 속았네 하면서 쭉
내려왔는데 이번에는 그런
크 굵직굵직한 걸로 올라간게 아니라
어이 트렌드의 야모래퍼시픽이 적응을
좀 하면서 올리브형 쪽으로도 이제
입점한지 한 2년 차 정도 된 걸로
알고 있고요. 원래 생건이나 올리브형
아 생권이나는 올리브형 쪽으로 후나
설화수를 입점하진 않았거든요.
>> 그런 것도 [목을 가다듬음] 이제
입점하면서 어 좀 트렌드에 맞는
회사로 좀 변모를 하고 있고
마케팅에도 힘을 좀 많이 쓰고
있거든요. 생건이랑 좀 다르게. 어
그런 부분들이 이제 효과가 나타나고
있고 아까 중국 쪽도 연구님이 코멘트
해줬지만 거기 오프라인 매장을
계속해서 지금 축소하고 있잖아요.
중국 노출도를 좀 줄이면서 미국이나
유럽 쪽에 대한 어 매출 확대를 지금
회사가 사업 방향성을 좀 잘 바꾸고
있다라는 생각은 들거든요. 그래서
일본 계실적도 나쁘지 않았고 그래서
이전처럼 여기서 EPS가 또 폭
이렇게 꺾일 만한 이슈는 없지 않을까
그런 생각이 듭니다. 자, 퓨티
박사, 왕박사를한테
한번 물어보셨습니다.
>> 네.
영초 제가 그대 말씀드렸는데 뭐
실전도는 나쁘지 않아요. 환율 때문에
나가는 되게 많고요.
>> 이거는 관영사는 실 다 죽고 근데
뭐이 시전은 요동성 수급 너무 좋지
않으니까 주가는 내려갔습니다. 원래
이런 화전파 회사 패턴이 어 전에 그
오장님도 많이 얘기했어요. 선반기를
올라가고 하반기도 떨어지고 그래서 그
병구점 바로 병구조는 바로 그
2분기 실적 발표할 시점이에요.
>> 어 2분기
>> 네
>> 아직 발표 안 했죠?네 그래
보세요.이 시점은 항상 좋게 나올 수
있어요. 근데 항상 그때부터 픽도
돼요.
>> 하반 계속 약해하고 이유가 하반기 그
화점프는이 집회는 또 많이 해하니까
마게비
>> 그래서 하반기는 축대가 그렇게 죽지
않다고 생각하고 있어요. 선반기는
그냥 주가 출근한 동 오라 하는 거는
나쁘지 않고요. 실조는 단기적으로는
[콧방귀]
별 문제가 없지만 근데 그 중국 그
마케팅은 잘 모르겠습니다. 항선은
회사가 좋게 얘기하고요. 실적으로
보면 계속 비 나와요. 예. 그래서
어디까지 가는지 모르겠어요. 이미 몇
번 당했잖아요. 몇 년간 최근 계속
당했어요. 그래서 그 상황을 좀 봐야
하고요. 이런 회사가
뭐 좀 밸류가 싸니까 좀 사는 사람이
있긴 있는데
그 다른 회사에서 우리 그 ARP
이런 회사 대비는 좀 약해. 몸은
실전 몸통일까
>> 예전에 중국 요커들이 뭐 물터시
들어왔을 때
>> 실라오테 면세점에 우리가 그때
가보기도 했잖아요.
>> 그죠?이
>> 지극 벌검 받은 걸로
>> 실러 면세 가서 왕박사 보고 한번
보고 오라고 했었던게 2015년 뭐
요때였던 거 같은데 요즘도 많이
들어오거든. 많이 들어오는데 지금은
이제 신라 면세점이 아니라 올리버형
>> 올리버형에서 뭐가 잘 팔리나 그걸
봐야 된다 그랬었는데 지금 보면
관광객들이
진짜 많이 들어와요. 진짜 많이
들어오는데
>> 요즘 다시 이제 면세점에서 이거
뭐니퍼시픽
소화수나 후를 산다든지 이런 분위기는
요즘은 아예 없어요.
>> 음. 좀 그렇게 세지 않고요.이 원래
그 홍콩 도매선들이 한국 와서 면세점
거의 가고 그 대령 구매하고 대국이
홍했잖아요. 요즘에
>> 어리비안 빅세일이잖아요. 어리비안
물량은 생기고 홍콩에서 보내는 구조를
박았어요.
>> 어네
>> 그래서이 트렌드가 좀 박았어요. 그럼
빅세일 할 때 가서 사고.
>> 네. 그
>> 근데 옛날에는 면세점이나 이런 거 뭐
살 때 뭐
>> 네.
>> 저 리베이터도 많이 주고 그랬었잖아.
뭐 매출액에 한 20%까지도 막 주고
했었는데 올리브형에서 사갈 때는 그런
건 없어요.
>> 음. 아마 이미 컬러 만들었는데요.
아니 오르비안 픽셀 아 얘기해도
되나요?
>> [웃음]
>> 약 좀 위험 있는데
>> 옛날에 그 올리비언은 한 개바닥은
하나 수 있잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 아, 얘기하면 안 들어가지. [웃음]
아무튼 네. 그런 거 이거고 봐어요.
네.
>> 네.
>> 죄송합니다.
>> 아, 죄송합니다. [웃음]
>> 네.
>> 알겠어요?
>> 네네. 하여튼
이번에는 저거 아모리퍼스픽이 주가
최근에 화장품 강한데
>> 이번에는 좀 어떻게 믿어봐도 돼요?
어때요?
>> 뭐 실적 발표하기 전에는 아마 모문턴
계속 받을 수 있습니다. 네.
>> 2분기 실적 발표할 때까지는 좋고
발표하고 나면 또 꺾인다고. 어마 좀
실적 기다감면 이미 다 소통되잖아요.
>> 근데 4 5 6이고 2분기가
>> 789가 보통 휴가 처리고 하니까
>> 화정품 소비가 오히려 더
늘어나잖아요.
>> 아 왜냐면 789 그때 물량 이미
2개도 보냈어요.
>> 아 물량을 이미 보냈으니까.
>> 맞아요.
>> 그렇네. 우리가 의류나 이런 것도
보면 옛날에 나이티나 아디다스 영어
모욕에서 보면 상반기가 실적이 좋고
오히려 연말에 팔기 위해서 미리
물량이 언제 나가는 거 같아.
789 주가가 좋았던 적이 거의 없을
보면 대부분 2분기 실적 발표가 주가
측면에서 꼭대기였는데 원래 그럼
그전에 많이 올라갔어야 되는데
이번에는 전혀 못 올라갔을 것
같아요.
>> 그런 부분은 조금 다르네.
>> 알겠.
자, 활용품은요 정도 받고
그다음에 삼형식품 보겠습니다.
최근에 삼형식품 주가도 조금씩 도는
거 같긴 한데요. 여전히 추세는 좀
밑에 있긴 하지만 내용을 좀
살펴보겠습니다. 2분기 실적에 대한
이야기고요. 하나 시문주 연구원
자료였습니다.
어, 시장 기대치 정도 나올 거다라는
추정인데요. 매출 7,200억, 영업
이익 1770억
전망했습니다. 그래서 오피 마진이 한
25% 정도로 나쁘지 않은 영업익을
기록할 것으로 보고 있고요. 관세청에
따르면 4월에서 5월 누개의 삼양식품
수출액은 전년 동기 대비 24%
증가하는 것으로 추산이 되고
있습니다. 사측에 의하면 6월
들어서도 미주 및 중국의 견조한
판매가 이어지고 있는 것으로 파악이
된다라고 하고요.이를 감안했을 때
2분기 수출 성장률 1분기와 유사한
YY 40% 정도 내외가 될 것으로
예상을 했습니다.
국내도 우지라면이 200억 정도 내외
매출 기여하면서 분기 1,억 원 정도
흐름이 이어질 것으로 판단을 했고요.
북중미 월드컵 등 글로벌 광판비
증가가 손익을 입부 훼손시킬 것이라는
우려가 있었지만 우호적인 환율이이를
좀 상세할 것이다. 원하 대비 달러미
위한나 모두 강세 흐름이 이어지고
있어서 전사실적에 긍정적 영향을 미칠
것으로 보고 있고요. 하반기 베이스
부담이 있긴 한데 중국 공장 가동
이후 레벨업까지 가능하지 않을까라는
전망입니다. 어 미량 이공장 가동
속도가 가팔라지면서 실적 기효도가
커지고 있다라고 하는데요. 미량은
유형 근무제를 통해 이교대 교체 이후
부족한 일순을 상쇄 중에 있다라고
하고 물론 첫가동 시점 감안 시
하반기는 베이스에 대한 부담감이
상존한다라고 합니다. 해외 성장률은
올해 상반기 yy 40% 하반기에는
30% 정도 내외로 다소 둔화될
것으로 보고 있고요. 그러나 연말
내년 초공장 가동에 따른 또 한 번에
레벨업비가 가능한만큼 중장기적
관점에서 바라볼 필요가 있겠다. 가격
매력 높아진 주가라고 하는데 최근 두
개 분기 손익 훼손 우려인의 주가는
27년 코드 밸류 13배 수준까지
빠졌습니다. 어 글로벌 피어 밸류
대비 밴드 하단이 15배인 점 감안해
보면 단기 가격 매력이 커진
상황이라고 하고요. 2분기 실적도
우려와는 달리 시장 기대에 부합하는
수준 정도로 나올 것으로
추정했습니다. 내년을 바라보면 저가
매수 기회로 판단할 수가 있다.
전망했습니다.
실적 내려가서 보면요. 올해 예상
매출액이 2조 9천억입니다.
그중에 해외 매출이 2조 5천억
정도고요. Y와Y 성장률로 보면 국내
12% 해외가 33%
추정이 되고 있습니다. 그래서 해외
쪽 성장률이 뭐 낮아지곤 있다곤
하지만 여전히 어 30% 이상의 높은
성장률이 기대가 되고 있는
상황이고요. 어 영업 이익 기준으로
보면 올해 7,억 정도 나올 것으로
추정을 하고 있는데 y로 34%
증가 전망입니다. 그래서 마진도
24%기 때문에 어 지난해 대비
1.7% 포인트 정도 올라갈 것으로
추정이 되고 있고요. 환율 영향을
확실히 많이 갖고 있는 거 같습니다.
그리고 오른쪽은 EPS 주의와
밸루에이션인데요. EPS는
계속해서 지금 올라가고 있음에도
불구하고 밸류는 계속해서 내려온
상황이거든요. 어
밸루에이션은
적어도 한 18배 정도까지는 올라갈
수 있는 여력 20배 정도 있지
않을까라고 생각이 들고요. 물론 그
이상은 가기 어렵다라고 좀 생각을
하긴 하지만 여전히 좀 14배면 지금
유통 회사 14배 봤거든.
>> 근데품 14배 조금 너무한게 아니냐
생각이
>> 들거든요. 그래서
소비제 음식 섹터에서는 가장 매력적인
선택치 중에 하나지 않을까? 그래서
이익 성장이 30%가 나오는데 그리고
전문이 말씀해 주셨던 글로벌 경쟁력이
있는 회사인데 14배면
정상적인 시장 상황이었다면 이런
밸류까진 빠지지 않았지 않았을까?
음. 그런 생각이 듭니다.
최근에 어 주식 시장에 대한 설명을
드릴 때 제가 이형식품을 예를
들으면서 많이 얘기하거든요.
아이스크림 해. 해가 쨍쨍할 때
폭염이 왔을 때 아이스크림이 잘
팔리고 우산이 안 팔리고 근데
우리나라는 계절적으로 보면 항상
장마도 있고 비도 가끔 쇼우기
때문에이 우산은 완전히 버려야 되나?
생각보면 우산이 항상 필요해 보면.
그래서 비가 올 때는 다시 우산
장사가 잘 되고 아이스크림 장수는
아이스크림이 안 팔리고 그런 표현은
마크위치의 포트폴리오 이론을 공부할
때 그고 표현을 많이 쓰잖아요.
그죠?
>> 예.
그러면 마코위의 포트폴리오 이론은 왜
노벨상을 받았을까
보면 되게 단순한 논문이었어요. 그
마코이츠가 박사를 하면서 썼던
논문인데
노벨상을 받았는데 한 종목 몰했을
때에 나는 100% 수익하고 우산하고
아이스크림하고 반반 나눠서 했을 때에
나오는 똑같은 100% 수익인데도
불구하고 어 변동성이 이게 확
줄어들구나.
그래서 똑같은 수익이라도이
변동성이 줄 수 있다라는 거. 그래서
분산 투자의 효과가 어이 어떻다라는
걸 증명을 하면서 되게 단순했는데
그래서 밀튼 프린드만 아니었나? 어떤
교수가 뭘 이런 걸 박사 논문이라고
썼어. 되게 평화했었어.
나중에 법배상을 받을 정도로 예,
그런 개념을 우리가 좀 이해를 하시면
좋은데 지금
우리 최부 사장님이 요런 그 차트를
늘 갖고 오시잖아요. 그죠? EPS는
계속 어 펀더멘탈이 계속
>> 올라가는데 어 주가가 빠질 때는 사면
된다. 이런 얘기 많이 하시잖아요.
>> 예. 그런데 지금 옆에 보면 매출액
증가율이
고가장 얘기한 대로 매출액 증가율이
24년 44.9 작년에도 36 올해도
24.9인데
>> 예
>> 어 영업 이익도 보면
회전 이익도 뭐 124.9 46.9
무 38%
어 되게 높아요.
>> 이익증가도 놓고
>> 어 아니 괜찮은데 근데 뭐 주가는
보점 대비 이렇게 유통해서 맞은 어
PR 정도까지 뭐 떨어지는 이런
모습이 나오는 게
>> 근데
>> 반도체 해펫이 너무 쨍하다는 거죠.
6월 달에 수출 데이터도 나왔지만
199% 증가하다 보니까 소위 말해서
깨갱하는 거죠. 어 잘 나가고
있었는데 옆에서는 막 200% 증가나
보니까
>> 거기서 이제 깽개가 하는 거고요.
그래서 지금 상대적인 매력도가 떨어져
있는 건데이 상대적인 매력도
주가가 안 빠지고 옆으로 이렇게
기는게
오히려 정상적일 것 같은데 에이 이거
팔아서 반도체에 사야지 지금 뭘
>> 어 라면 먹고 있는 거야 이러면서
저쪽으로 가다 보니까
>> 저렇게 빠져 있고
같은 주식은 내년 년 내후년에 실적이
어떻게 될까 생각해 보면 이게 아 저
실적이 과연 나올까? 그 나오겠죠.
이게 가시성이 좀 뛰어난 여자기
때문에
>> 그래서 어 3치면 장기적으로 지금
투자하고 계신 분들은 틀림없이 아
내가 뭘 잘못 보고 있나? 종목만
쳐다보고 계신 분들은 내가 뭘 잘못
보고 있나 그러실 건데 지금은
말씀드린 대로 반도체 패이 너무
쨍쟁해죠.
그 이런 주식은 반도체 [콧방귀]
햇볕이 이제 약간 흐려지고
>> 그런 조집이 나오면 이런 주식들이
이제 덜썩덜썩 이제 올라갈 것
>> 그런 차원에서 주식을 비성상적인 거
같아 보인다 얘기했었는데 주식 시장은
항상 예 정상적으로 작동을 하는데
솔림은 있어요.
대중들의이 솔림 그 솔림은 보면 약간
비이성적으로
비성적으로 움직이는 그 부분도 시장의
한 모습이
아시면 될 것 같습니다.
자, 어 상향 10분까지
얘기를 해 주셨고 실적 발표가 나올
건데 시장 기대는 충족할 전방이다.
요렇게 하나 시문주 연구분께서 얘기를
해 주셨습니다. 자, 시간이 9시가
됐는데 야간 선물이 어제 1.84
빠졌기 때문에 오늘도 하락 한
1.5% 마이너스 요렇게 시작하네요.
>> 근데 예상은 플러스네요.
>> 예상은 네. 예상은 플러스 0.5%
상승해서 출발할 것으로 예상이 되고
있고요. 아직까지는 [콧방귀]
지금 이제 정확한 수치는 나오지 않고
있는 상황입니다.
>> 네. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 어제 코스피 코스닥 예. 코스닥도
처음에는 좀 나 상대적으로는 나쁘지는
않았는데 같이 우르 밀려 버리는 그런
모습이 나왔습니다.
호스피 연초 이후로 이제 81%
6월 말까지 101.1% 출반하고
똑같이 올랐잖아요. 예. 네.
>> 어제 제가 그 월관전망 하고 나서
그런 얘기를 해 주어요.이
>> 많이 올란 주식을 어
>> 그래도 사람들이 보면 많이 오를
때까지
그 끌고 간게 참 대단한 거잖아요.
끌고 간게 참 대단한 건데 많이 올란
주식이 지금 A 뭐 100% 하다가
지금 80% 그럼 20% 마이너스다.
>> 그렇습니다. 20% 마이너스인데
사실은 이게 40% 마이너스라는
거죠. 왜냐면이 100% 올랐잖아요.
그럼 뭐 5, 만천이 만
>> 그게 5,이 만 됐으니까 100% 수
있잖아.
>> 근데만이 8, 된 거죠.
>> 12,
>> 20% 빠졌으니까. 그렇죠.
>> 어,
>> 100% 올랐으면 우리가 이제 5,을
기준으로
>> 하면 5,원이 만 원 되면
100%죠.
>> 예. 그렇죠. 예. 예.
>> 100% 올랐는데 그 만 원에서
20% 빠지면 지금 요런 요런
거잖아요. 80 연초 이후 81%면
>> 아 기준점이요? 그러니까 쉽게
얘기해서 100이 [콧방귀]
100이 200이 되면 100%가
오른 거잖아요.
>> 그중에서 이제 한 10% 빠지면은
어 200이 180이 되잖아요.
>> 내가 설명을 잘 내가 설명을
잘못했다예. 그렇게 된 거죠. 기준점
자체가 위에서 되니까 작은 수익률에도
불구하고 밑에서 보면은
>> 누적 수익률은 작게 되는 거죠.
>> 맞아요.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 고점 만 원에서 10%
빠지면이
만 원에서 10% 빠지면 9천인데
>> 네.
>> 근데 그 5천을 기준으로 보면 5천이
많이 됐을 때는 내 수익이
100%인데
>> 예. 어 많이 부천되면 내수익률은
이제 5천에서 9천이 됐기 때문에
80% 지금 딱 그런 거.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 예.
>> 그래서 고점 대비 만약에 20%
빠졌다. 고점에서 20% 빠졌다.
>> 그렇게 되면 이제만이 8천이 되는
건데
>> 5천 기준으로 보면 아 100%
나타가 돼 버리.
>> 맞습니다. 예. 맞습니다.
>> 그래서 고점 대비 뭐 종목들로 보면
고점 대비 뭐 35% 이렇게 막 빠진
주식들 많았잖아요.
그분들이 되게 마음이 허탈해지는게
고점 대비 40% 빠졌다고 치고
최근에 종목들 40% 많이 빠졌으니까
40% 빠졌으면 실제로는 5,이 만
원 갔다가 다시 6천 됐으니까
>> 그러면 아씨 100% 수익 났던게
20%로 줄
>> 맞습니다.
그런 데기 때문에
고점해서이 베타가 높은 종목들한
보면은 어 확 움직이다 보니까
맞습니다.
>> 그리고 우리나라 종목들이 또
>> 이번에 중수영주들도 맞지만
순식하네요. 순간
>> 순식하네요.
그래서 다들 이제 좀 타격감이
큰 이유가 내 수익을 갉아먹는게
먹었던 수익을 토해내는게 두 배로
토해내는 그런 소식이 나오기 때문에
>> 어떻게 됐을까요?
>> 네. 시장 시작했고요. 어 플러스
1.2%로 어 코스피 지수는 상승에서
출발 시작했고요. 어 현재는 플러스
0.68%로 68%로 소폭 내려와
있는 상태입니다.
그리고 코스닥은 마이너스네요.
>> 네. 코스닥도 플러스 0.98%로
상승 출발은 했었고요. 어 현재는
-0.32%
0.4% 정도 하락하고 있습니다.
자 오늘 밤은 미국 시장은 없습니다.
그렇죠. 그렇습니다.
>> 유리프로 좀 마음이 홀가분하겠어요.
예. 그리고
>> 네. 유리프는
그동안에이 소영대리가 유가 휴직을
가면서
아침 모닝 브리프에서 미국 시장을
담당을 해 줬었는데 유리프로가 이제
인턴 기간이 끝나고
그래서 오늘까지
모닝 브리퍼는 마지막입니다.
하지만 내일 별주분에는 나옵니다.
내일 인사를 한번 더 하긴 하겠지만
브이프를 애청하시는 우리 애청자분들을
위해서
인사 한 마디 하시죠.
한 달 동안 많이 배웠고 성장했고
좋은 댓글 남겨 주셔서 감사했습니다.
앞으로도 채슬리에서 배운 거 기반으로
더
시장 공부해 나가겠습니다.
>> 한 달어요?
>> 네.
별주 부전을 두 달 좀 넘게
했습니다.
>> 아, 별주 부전은 두 달 했고.
>> 네.
>> 그러니까 한 달 한 거 같지 않고
월라수목 금토까지 계속 보다 보니까
되게 한 두 달 나는
석달한 느낌이 이런 느낌이 들었는데.
>> 그러니까 어 서형 대리가
>> 6월부터 유가주이 가서
>> 맞습니다. 예.
한달했는데
수준은 몇 년 한 것처럼음 굉장히
높았습니다.
>> 많은 분들이 이제 아쉬어 가지고
솔트님은 영원히 함께 할 줄
알았어요.
근데 유리프로가 우리가 주말
별주부전도 있고 하기 때문에
별주부전에서도
어 진행을 또 중간중간에 또 게스트로
또
출할 거기 때문에
또 멀리 가는게 아니라 또 여의도에서
또 다른 회사 가서도 인터도 하고
여러 가지 경험을 싸우러 가는 거기
때문에
자 그러면 어
한국 시장 어제 양봉 난다고 했는데
>> 아 맞아요. 어제 양봉 뭐
>> 큰복 났어.
>> 음
>> 왕박사
>> 네
>> 오늘은 어떻게 돼요?
>> 오늘 자기 음봉이 있습니다.
>> 다시 음봉
>> 마음이 오락가락 하는 거 아니야? 아
저 마음이 시스템 마음
>> 시스템 마음이 왕박사 마음은 아니다
마음
>> 안봉네
>> 안봉입니다.
>> 시스템 미포하는 거죠? 네. 코스피
어제 음보. 네. 예수.
오늘은 금요일이
미국이 휴장인데 다음 주에 이제
반도체 실적 발표가 예정이 되어
있잖아요. 그래서
금요일이지만 오늘 메모리들의 반등이
좀 나오면서
근데 시초가 좀 높게 시작해 가지고
좀 애매하긴 한데 양봉 예상해
보겠습니다. 어 양보은
코스피 양보 아닌가요?
>> 예 양봉하겠습니다.
>> 소신 [목을 가다듬음] 있게. 네
[웃음]
>> 아니 나보다는 오가정이 후신 맞죠?
모여보겠습니다.
>> 그냥 내가 이제 파생할 때 경험으로는
>> 네.이
>> 어제처럼 그렇게 빠지면이 올라오다가도
어제 보면 사람들이 어제 월간
전방에서도 복부장 같은 경우에도
8시초가에 날렸다가 종가에 다시 한
60% 담았다 이러 많이 빠졌으니까
>> 많이 빠졌으니까 어제 종가에 사고
싶어지거든.
>> 음. 근데 어제 종가에 샀던 사람들은
오늘 또 올라오면이
또 팔려고 할 거고
>> 안 판 사람들은 어 그래 어제 그런
하락을 겪고 나면 아씨 올라오면 좀
팔아야 되나 또 그런 마음도 좀 들고
그런데 이게 외국인 수급이 사실은 뭐
제일 중요하 수급이 여기다가도 뭐
계속 그 24년 7월 8월이 그랬잖아
14년 7월 8월에 삼성전자가 이제
콜테스트 통과 뭐 있을 수 있다 뭐
이러고 있는데도 뭐 외국인들이 그렇게
뭐 때려팔더니 8월 초에 앵캐리
트레이터 청산 나오고
>> 나중에 모건스텐이 저성자가 나타나서
반도체으로 올 수 있다.
>> 네. 그 얘기하는 바람에 그때부터 8
9 10 11 12 1 2 3 4
7월부터 빠져서니까 25년 4월
트럼프 만세대 바닥 짚고 돌아서
외국인 외국인은 근데 지금 벌써 또
1조 한 7,억 파는 거예요.
>> 현재 한 5,억 정도 파는 걸로
보입니다.
>> 아 5,억인가? 이거 어제 건가?
5,억 정도.
>> 어 5,억 정도.
>> 네.
5,억이면 잠깐. 지금 시간이
10분이 안 됐는데. 네.
>> 다행히 기관 쪽에서는 매수를 좀
잡히네. 이제 640억 정도 잡히네.
640억 정도.
그래서 그냥 기술적 운호만 보면 어
장대 음봉이나 장대 양봉 나왔을 때
나는 플레이를 많이 했었는데 돼.
그러면 장대 양봉이 나오면 그다음날
시초가부터 마이너스 한 2%까지 매수
쫙 걸어 놓거든. 그러면 어 뭐야
많이 올랐네. 오늘 좀 팔아야지
하면서 그 파는 수요가 아침에 있어
가지고 좀 밀리다가
>> 다시 이제 올라가는 그런 모습이
말이에요. 장대 음봉이 나오면 이제
반대 케이스
알겠습니다. 7,600 정도에서 제거
왔다 갔다 하는 모습이 나오고
월간 전망 자료가
버스 플랫폼에는 오늘 중으로 올라갈
거고요. 저희 고객 계시는 카페에도
오늘 월간 전망이 올라갈 거니까
참고하시기 바라겠습니다.
>> 자, 오늘 채슬님 모닝 브리크는
여기까지 하도록 하겠습니다. 어,
치는 것부터 투자라고.
>> 예.
>> 내 종목에 대한 컨빅션이 있으면 그냥
덮어 놓고 버티시면 되고
>> 현금을 좀 가지고 계신 분들이라든지
아, 신경 쓰에서
어떡하지? 뭐 그런 분들은 점검을 좀
많이 만들어 놓으시고 쉬도 돼요. 한
달 동안 뭐 왔다 갔다 왔다 갔다
하다가
>> 보면 다시 방향 잡고 올 연말부터
내년에 또 큰 장이 또 노래하기
때문에 마음까지 계절 관리할 일 잘
하시길 바라겠습니다.
>> 행복한 주말 보내시고 저희는 내일
5시에 별주전에서 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
고맙습니다. 감사합니다.